all right so we don't have a verdict yet
in the Kyle Rittenhouse trial but today
was still pretty crazy because it turns
out the prosecution provided manipulated
evidence to the defense now they argue
oh no it was an accident we didn't
realize and it's the defense's fault for
not having iPhones but uh basically what
happened is the prosecution had high res
video and gave the defense low res video
which is worse than just withholding
evidence but we're still waiting the
jury will come back I guess the judge
this is kind of crazy the judge said
he's not going to make a decision on a
mistrial with president's Prejudice
mistrial with prejudice but he told the
prosecutors I warned you there would be
a reckoning on that video
but we're gonna wait to see what the
jury comes back with in the terms of
their verdict the judge very well may
just let Rittenhouse off because of a
mistrial with prejudice that was filed
we'll see so we'll talk about all of
that too but we got big news I was right
oh I said I was right y'all told me I
was crazy
see when when it came yes it could be
both when it came to Alec Baldwin and
the shooting on set I said why are we
assuming it's an accident well guess
what the script supervisor the person
who knows what's supposed to go down has
filed a lawsuit against Alec Baldwin
saying he knew he was improperly handed
the gun he knew he shouldn't have
trusted the uh the ad said and he wasn't
supposed to aim it pull the trig [ __ ]
the hammer or pull the trigger so why
did he do it she said he played Russian
Roulette on set sounds like what she's
saying is he was screwing around pointed
it now there's a question of whether or
not you can argue it was an intentional
act to point the gun and pull the
trigger and how is it even manslaughter
when you point a gun at someone so we'll
talk about all that plus we got big news
the vax Mandate has been suspended a big
victory uh we've won the battle but not
the war so we got a lot to get into and
we're hanging out with of course Michael
malis and Mike cernovich yeah so well
you can't you you gotta say words
because the podcast people can't see you
no I don't like to acknowledge them
okay thanks Michael please do not speak
to me directly okay well all right you
certavich will say we'll say we'll go by
last names I'm usually pretty quiet
[Laughter]
yeah you want to introduce yourself just
yeah yeah Mike cernovich I'm here
visiting from great overlap here in the
mobile Studio of timcast I always
introduce myself as an entity who exists
because I don't really have a hook right
I used to have like a hook here's what I
do here's what I do now and I've been
semi-retired for a couple of years so
all I just say is that I'm alive
existing doing whatever but there's no
thing like here's a thing is a podcaster
he's a you're a lawyer though right yeah
yeah I mean a lawyer filmmaker author
you tweet a lot
you're the OG gorilla it's not Alex
that's true it's not Alex Jones you're
the first gorillas right well I
pioneered the whole mindset genre for
men so my mindset book was the first of
that genre so it's always funny when
people
they're like oh you're you're trying to
pretend that you're like Jordan Peterson
and I was like dude my like I was before
him like well before him so whatever it
doesn't mean he's not good or bad but
it's weird because they'll people like
I've I found that they find you at a
point in time and you never existed
before that point yeah right right you
know what it's like it's like when you
hear a cover song and thinks theory if
it's the original that you heard it
first that's actually a really
interesting thing because I was just
playing I was jamming outside and I was
playing The Man Who Sold the World oh
Bowie and there's a funny song a funny
story Bowie had where he said he played
The Man Who Sold the World on set and
two teenage girls were like that was so
cool how you covered Nirvana
so Bowie
Avril Lavigne didn't even know who he
was wow wow
I'm glad you're here actually you're
you're a lawyer so you're gonna have way
more understanding of a lot of these
This legal stuff with Alec Baldwin and
with the writtenhouse stuff so excited
you're here true um and Michael malice
of course is here but I guess he
introduced himself everybody knows who
he is hello I thought I thought after
yesterday we're all gonna kind of take
it back a step and let each other talk
when you're with Alex it's kind of a
competition to talk there's actually
some they're hater videos but every now
and then a hater video is funny which is
usually not and it'll show Alex talking
and it's me just sitting there and the
video is titled like Mike cernovich
fails job interview for Infowars because
I'm just sort of like hey and then Alex
will like look over to you and I'm like
okay am I supposed to talk now what what
exactly is supposed to happen here so if
all the hater videos that one is is
actually funny you just have to scream
whenever you get an opportunity to do so
and then that's the only way to get your
voice out howdy welcome beautiful and
amazing human beings my name is
lucrative we are change.org and I once
again wanted to thank YouTube for
demonetizing me and making me a very
humble t-shirt vendor the t-shirt that
I'm wearing right now is one of the
shirts that I sell and it's a picture of
a prophet and a saint Mr Dr Ron Paul and
it says if I told you so it was a person
then you could get yours exclusively on
the best of politicalshirts.com and
that's the way to support me thanks so
much for having me thanks for having me
it's Ian crossing over here I'm ready to
take control of this show and uh lead
the way yeah just kidding I got some I
got some amazing powerhouses in the uh
in the house and so I'm gonna let you
guys display yourselves
but I am really looking forward to this
battle the Michaels I hope it's not
actually a battle I'm hoping to have a
super cool conversation as well Mike
cernovich is not only one of my favorite
people but there's a handful of people
in my life where I'm comfortable
Outsourcing my decision making on
certain issues and he's one of them very
cool so there's not going to be any
fighting here at all speaking of of
personal life decisions Michael you are
an underwear model yeah that's true if
everyone goes to sheathunderwear.com and
use promo code malice you'll get 20 off
of your underwear and the good thing
about sheath is it has that dual pouch
technology for both parts of your male
anatomy and you can get one step closer
to getting inside my pants and the first
time you put it on you're like what the
hell is this and you even have the
little veins with uh the hip bone yeah
the [ __ ] gutters yeah yeah
that's like a lot of work family
friendly well well I mean I don't know
what the term is hip flexors
it took a lot of work to get to that
point so high five so you wanna and
there's a promo code promo code malice
you get 20 off and I'll say one thing
the first time I put them on I'm like
what the hell is this and now I wear
them every day because they're so
comfortable interesting so yeah and I'm
I'm proud to be able to uh
um do they have the power dual pouch oh
yeah one for one part of your parts and
another part for another part of your
power because the guy who found the
companies did time in Iraq where it's
very hot okay and this keeps you nice
and cool good for that RV life yeah
um well well thanks
don't forget everybody hope we we also
want to do a promo go to timcast.com
become a member we're gonna have a
members only segment going up around 11
or so p.m tonight and uh as a member
you're helping support our Fierce and
independent journalism there's actually
a story we have
it's graphic I can't show you but it's
an exclusive report from Cassandra
Fairbanks about
fauci's niaid funding what's called
maximum pain research on primates oh my
God this story is really brutal and oh
my God that's horrifying so uh
Cassandra's been working on this we have
the story up we'll talk about it but it
is absolutely horrifying they take
primates there's thousands of them and
they subject them to what's called
maximum pain experiments is that a
euphemism for like cuddles no it no it's
it's it's the photos are horrifying
that's why I'm like I can't scroll down
right now maybe we need like a graphic
filter for like because not everybody
wants to see this stuff but this is what
the kind of stuff that the Nia idea was
funding under fauci because we know
about the dogs so we'll get into all
that stuff not to be too much of a
Debbie Downer but uh become a member
support that independent work because I
got to be honest we take we take risks
with big exclusives like this because
you are you are you are making direct
accusations and there's there's real
risks to reporting people want to come
after you but go to timcast.com don't
forget to like this video right now like
this uh episode subscribe to the channel
share it wherever you can because that
really really does help taking the URL
putting whatever you can let's get into
this first story now
Rittenhouse is really really big you
know and we're waiting on this verdict
but we really are just waiting on this
verdict so I wanted to lead with
something in a similar vein that's big
and political so we decided to talk
about the the Alec Baldwin stuff because
I was right oh boy take a look at this
story we got this from The Daily Mail
Alec chose to play Russian Roulette rust
script supervisor breaks down in tears
as she sues Baldwin over Helena Hutchins
death because he cocked and fired the
gun even though the scene didn't call
for it she says Baldwin knew the gun
should have never been given to him and
that he could not rely on the assistant
director about whether or not the gun
was safe to use Mr Baldwin chose to play
Russian Roulette when he fired a gun
without checking it without having an
armorer within his presence I want to I
want to point something out this is what
I was saying uh last a couple weeks ago
everybody started this story saying it
was a misfire from a blank that shrapnel
hit this woman and I wonder I can't
remember who was telling us this but
maybe that was a PR response a crisis
management company for him leaked that
story because they're like if we start
with the premise that was an accident
everyone will believe it was an accident
no matter what and last week I said why
are we assuming it's an accident Alec
bought we'd have to assume the armor was
screwed up the assistant director
screwed up that Alec Baldwin screwed up
and then he pointed in the right
direction those are all crazy
assumptions how come we're not starting
from Alec Baldwin Paul Dagon pointed it
cocked it pulled the trigger and then
from there we can walk it back now this
is big the script supervisor the person
who knows exactly what's supposed to go
on on scene says he wasn't supposed to
have a gun right he should have checked
it and he didn't
he certainly wasn't supposed to pull the
hammer and pull the trigger that to me
sounds like a good argument for
intentional homicide I'm not a huge gun
person but every time I've handled the
gun the person handing it to me who's
actually a gun expert or just someone as
Aficionado gave me a speech and part of
that speech is you do not point a gun at
anything that you do not want to destroy
you assume every single gun you are
having it is loaded until you check it
personally you do not put your finger on
a trigger and if you screw up any one of
those you're still going to be safe and
just one more you don't act like a state
prosecutor
no but there is actually one more always
know what's behind your target okay yeah
what your target isn't Beyond that's
important here specifically for Baldwin
because if we're still operating under
the premise that he was pointing it at
the camera for a scene he wasn't paying
attention to what was beyond his Target
but I don't buy that for a minute look
if if we're going to talk about a guy
who wasn't supposed to be given a gun
she says she's a script supervisor
that's that's big wasn't supposed to
have it why did he have it why am I then
going to assume this wasn't murder
because you've got an angry crew you've
got people threatening to walk offset
Baldwin says I had a dinner with her
just that Friday sounds to me and I said
this before she was actually negotiating
him with him or arguing with him and
then he goes on set takes the gun and
says bam oh no oh no oh geez that's like
pure psycho if he did you're saying that
the rumor that went around that he
jokingly said how about it just kill you
both that that was a false room yeah yes
someone someone that was clever it was a
clever hoax I almost fell for that one
too me too I actually recorded a video
oh and then someone responded with the
clip and I was like whoa cause I'm like
I'm like showing the article I'm showing
the tweet and then I see that and I was
like I don't know if that's true I gotta
check someone took a news article and
then altered the code to add that yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if it was his PR
team in order to muddy the waters
because a lot of times with this
information we see fake information
being brought out to the general public
to make everyone confused about what's
really going on there and you still you
saw bolded right right after the
incident he was right on the phone he
was probably talking to his PR people he
was trying to probably run cover he has
a lot of money he has a lot of influence
and there was a lot of cover we're just
finding out finding out about these
details now how many days later has it
been yeah so what else are they hiding
what else don't we know about when's the
investigation is there even an
investigation I mean what's going on
here everyone should be asking these
larger questions and they're not an
accident means different things right
there's if they're trying to make it out
as if he like just dropped the gun and
it like went off and showed someone when
you are pointing a gun at someone and
cocking a trigger you can't say that
that's an accident that's intentionality
oh sorry see I don't even know the terms
but even I know enough you don't point a
gun at someone but so this is this is
three steps well actually it's four he
drew the weapon he then pointed it he
then pulled the hammer back he then
pulled the trigger I mean that is very
intentional
yeah it's very disturbing too and it's
also disturbing how many people were on
their knees running interference for him
immediately conservatives especially is
that right oh yeah you get the whole
conservative oh it's such a tragedy I
can't believe Don Jr is politicizing
it's just like the spin cycle and the pr
thing you said I know is true because I
tweeted out man this is really weird the
engagement that I got anytime he tweeted
about Baldwin hundreds of replies
instantaneously and it was all you're
cruel you're vile how dare the victim
here yeah yeah it's amazing yeah and
then you even had conservatives going
along oh it's just a such a tragedy no
you know it well it's tragedy for the
woman of course right obviously but they
were definitely influencing the
conversation and then I do believe they
use this information via that article
because then they would go conspiracy
theorists they're trying to P gate Alec
Baldwin can you believe it look at these
Bad actors blah blah blah I don't know
if you know the answer to this question
uh
but is pointing a gun at someone a
felony
it's called brandishing as a legal term
brandishing a firearm and it definitely
depends on the context so if I were just
here with you guys and one of you you
know brandished a firearm without some
kind of intent then it wouldn't be but
it all depends on the context but then
if you came to uh to a bank and you just
tapped a gun that would be brandishing
even though you're not even pointing it
yes it was all based on the context
though and it also depends on the state
laws because in some states like Ohio
with the state prosecutor did in the
Kyle written a house case that's a
chargeable Wisconsin
um no no Ohio has a specific rule oh if
if he would have done the same thing in
that state he would have gone down for a
charge right right so here's why I ask
we have this from uh law.jessa.com this
is New Mexico statutes on homicide
section on manslaughter and it says
voluntary manslaughter consists of
manslaughter committed upon a sudden
quarrel or In the Heat of passion
whoever commits voluntary manslaughter
so I don't think that would apply here
they say involuntary manslaughter
consist of men Slaughter committed in
the commission of an unlawful act not
amounting to a felony or in the
commission of an uh of a lawful act
which might produce death in an unlawful
manner
or without due caution or circumspect
that's a fact they're both felonies and
the reason I ask is I'm wondering if by
simple first we can't call it an
accident an accident would be like you
said you drop it and it goes off and
you're like oh no and you might still
get in trouble because you're
responsible for that but this is a guy
who pulled it out and aimed it at the
woman
if is is so can we even argue this is
manslaughter if he pointed the gun at
her and pulled the trigger you would so
involuntary manslaughter
so the way they would say they could say
well an accident is still negligent so
the legal term is an accident's
negligent so you get in a car crash it's
an accident but who was negligent were
you looking at your cell phone at the
time so involuntary manslaughter the
textbook case of that is if you're
drinking and driving it isn't a felony
to drink and drive but somebody dies you
didn't intend for them to die so that's
usually when that would apply is there
was no intent for you to do gross bodily
harm or injury to someone else so with
the Alec Baldwin case we don't have
enough facts to know whether it be
voluntary or involuntary because and you
there's a whole I mean you could do a
whole week of this in law school and
then there's all kinds of cases on it
where you go from what's the difference
between Reckless versus negligent what's
the difference between willful and again
negligent and there's a lot of things
that depend on the facts so I would my
instinct from day one was that it would
have been involuntary manslaughter he
was recklessly he was acting with
callous or Reckless disregard for
another person's safety but I don't
think he actually wanted to murder her
or anything like that I don't think he
was pointing it at her I think he was
being Alec Baldwin who yeah is a
douchebag idiot well with rage issues
yeah as we know but uh George Clooney he
had a very interesting comment about
this he's usually a globalist stooge but
today he said I love you luke uh it's
true it's absolutely true I mean look
what he pushes uh but he came out and it
was talking about this specific case and
said that it was infuriating and it's
saying that this happened as he's
accusing Alec Baldwin Baldwin of
ignoring Decades of laws regarding
safety and firearms on set of movies so
even George Clooney is coming out
calling him out saying he wasn't doing
what he was supposed to do there's
something here that's not right and Adam
Baldwin also collaborate corroborated
that he said a few weeks ago I know
there's no love lost between the two
brothers he goes I've been in movie sets
and for there's a process for decades
that people go through before you're
handed a gun because us and this is
something that gun Advocates talk about
all the time even though the anti-gun
people don't say this they know very
well a gun is not a toy you are handling
a weapon that is can kill someone and
you have to treat that with the respect
it is due so uh let me let me start from
from from this uh premise for you uh
cernovich a man who has Decades of
firearms training is on set
he has no there is nothing calling for
for brandishing displaying or even
holding a weapon
he then points it with a live round and
shoots and kills a woman that I mean
wouldn't an investigator or a D.A go
straight for intentional homicide no
that would be voluntary manslaughter
because that would be Reckless versus
negligent you're still not an
intentional murder because he didn't
intend to kill someone wait but but
there's no reason to have a gun if I
walk out in the middle of the street and
and pull out a gun and shoot somebody
they're gonna say intentional homicide
right
if
again it varies in the context how big
was the crowd were you celebrating a uh
Fiesta or something let's say this I
walk into the middle of the street and
there's a person filming me with a
camera I pull out a gun [ __ ] the hammer
shoot him and kill him oh yeah that
would be intentional murder yeah so Alec
Baldwin I think this is why I ask if
we're approaching it from the context of
he wasn't supposed to have a gun
that means he walked up pointed the gun
at a woman for no reason which he wasn't
supposed to have and decided to shoot
her why would we operate as if that was
like manslaughter because it's the
context of the relationship it's the
same thing where if you were on a first
date with a girl and she fell asleep and
you you know looked for some action that
would be sexual assault potentially but
if it's your wife or your girlfriend
then there's a consent a pattern of
consent so it's different because of the
relationship so the law that's why the
law is hard he's in a dispute with the
crew they were threatening to walk
offset well that you know that would be
the case that people would make in their
case would say that we we have a working
relationship that's existed here he
pulled out the gun he was I see I see
yeah yeah so it's very you get it I mean
laws really I love having these
conversations it's all about getting in
the weeds and everything is about facts
and circums and that's why law drives
people crazy because it's all context
based and one fact can literally change
the whole outcome did you see the the
clip when Alec Baldwin was outside his
house like yelling at reporters and
there were two things that were really
clear from that clip that I found one
disturbing one not disturbing one is he
very very clearly feels horrible about
this like this is not something where he
went to bed that night it's like it'll
be fine he's disturbed by this as
virtually anyone is who's responsible
for killing someone else but he also
clearly feels that because he's so upset
that means he suffered enough and leave
me alone and that to me is a big problem
you don't get to decide well I feel
really bad I'm suffering shut up and go
away that's not how it works because you
did something that was extremely
preventable and one person is dead and
he might have been a real quick
correction people are pointing out Adam
Baldwin is not a Baldwin brother oh okay
another thing to really consider here is
that Alec Baldwin went to anger
management before because of his rage
issues and because of other court
proceedings that he had related to of
course blowing up and getting really
angry and uh you know committing acts of
uh either harassment or assault against
other people so there is a long history
here of someone who isn't control of his
emotions to the point where he has
sought professional help so that's
another thing that to consider what if
what if he clearly does feel bad about
this but not for her for him like oh man
I got really mad I just I pulled the
trigger I shouldn't have done that but
was he mad it seemed like he was doing
it very matter-of-factly well well he's
an actor too he's an actor too so we
have to consider that when he's
portrayed he's the most I don't think
he's that good of an actor maybe
as Jack Donaghey was
oh that's a cartoon character right
right I think it's very hard to make the
case that yeah he's not disturbed by
seeing someone he was at least if one of
you right now God forbid something
happened we'd all be you're making
assumptions you're making assumptions
that this is the issue I took with the
case initially we don't know they were
friends I didn't say they were friends
even if it's just some random we almost
said they were friends you're about to
say they were friends Alex said they
were friends but what I'm saying is even
if it's someone like you know a person
you've had just a conversation with at a
party and in front of you you saw them
get shot and bleed out I think the vast
vast majority of people will be
traumatized for life
especially if you're the one who pulled
the trigger the D.A says they know who
put the bullets and the gun oh yeah that
was something that came out a while ago
so I guess in this case I mean final
thoughts you think they're gonna
actually charge him for anything because
it's the stuff starts coming out from
Witnesses I say no no no really what's
they're not getting out of conviction
just some people are above the law yeah
and he Alec Baldwin would
fall into that category you think
they'll charge the assistant director or
the armor so that I think a lot of money
will exchange hands and because Alec
Baldwin's gonna owe millions of dollars
to the family you know because if
they're either way if it's your friend
like if you accidentally killed the a
friend of yours you would go to the
family and be like look dude you don't
have to assume like what do you need
yeah yeah yeah yeah so so if they're
friends he's writing a big check if
they're not friends he's writing a big
check so if they're really if they
really are friends and the husband's
gonna say what good does it do to put
you in jail they're gonna go to the D.A
and say I don't want anybody charged
with this we're not going to cooperate
we're going to do the opposite it's
actually really interesting because I'm
sure it probably happens a lot where
someone does commit an act that results
in death that should be criminally
charged but the family who would
normally be complaining are just like no
we understand it was an accident you
know that the U.S has bag men who go to
the Middle East and when we accidentally
kill children we have write them out the
check to these families and when if it's
a boy they get a lot bigger of a check
than if we accidentally kill one of the
girls so this is actually U.S and
there's your taxes yeah and there's
Actuarial tables for how much you pay
off for these poor uh people in the
Middle East to basically lost their son
or daughter for no reason depending on
what country what neighborhood and the
age of the the child and how many other
siblings they had and it's and it's this
is where your tax dollars are going yeah
this is insane sometimes I wish this was
a cooking show and we could be like the
Cherry goes on the whipped cream and
then we all enjoy a nice Strawberry
Shortcake instead we're like after they
kill the child they send someone to pay
off the family
real real quick yeah real quick also too
is if you're a prosecutor and you have a
case it's going to be hard to prove
anyway so you're a prosecutor you can
file a case it's going to be hard to
prove and then the victim's family says
we don't want you to file it then you're
not going to file it because what do you
gain and it's very hard to make the case
in terms of sensing him that this is
something he would do again right right
right let's talk about right now son oh
yeah yeah so this uh last night we're
doing the members only show and like
right in the middle where like whoa
what's the story Jack basobic tweets out
that the the prosecution withheld
evidence from the Kyle right now's
defense team not true it's actually not
true what happened they sent manipulated
evidence to the defense team it's even
worse let me explain how bad this is
if the the prosecution they say they
have a Drone footage actually we have
this article right here this is uh from
Andrew branca day two defense files for
mistrial Prejudice you can see image
from the Drone footage if the
prosecution presented the Drone footage
in court the defense would have went
whoa whoa whoa we never we've never
received this evidence your honor bless
you so the prosecution instead gives
them grainy low res video now I think it
was a Mercator stream they played the
different videos side by side and if you
pulled up on the TV and you were given
that the defense had no way of knowing
that this was not the video they're
given the video they play it they say
it's a video it's Drone footage makes
sense to me only when the defense played
the video in the in the in the jury
instructions did the did the state go
our version is much clearer
our version is much clearer now a lot of
people are like how dumb are they why
would they admit it they had no choice
if the prosecution was attempting to
pull a fast one on the defense to make
sure they had no way to analyze the
video to form a defense
they were that means they need the jury
to see their version of the evidence
which is clearer when the defense played
it they went oh crap we need the jury to
only see our version and the reason the
defense is given the low res version is
so they can't formulate the defense on
time so he had no choice but to say our
version is clear let's play that instead
now normally I'd say it was an accident
the argument is they texted the video to
the defense team which compressed it
that's insane to do now the defense
should have caught that but it's not
their fault they're told they're gonna
be given the footage and the video and
they believe it to be true and correct
but I'm not going to give them the
benefit of that on this one they've
committed constitutional violations
they've ignored rulings from the judge
the judge says he's going to hold this
in his back pocket until a verdict but
he very well may come back out and say
mistrial with prejudice writtenhouse is
free to go and can ask Mike a question
because you're an attorney let's suppose
they they forgot right like there was a
video file and it's in a drawer and it's
like oops I forgot I have it now and I'm
a prosecutor in good faith and the
juries are very deliberating what am I
what can I do at that point as a
prosecutor who would be acting in good
faith yeah that would so Tech there's a
they call those Brady violations Brady
is information that could go to guilt or
innocence or deal with information and
sentencing so in other words it shows
you as um maybe a better person a woman
person than you thought so if it's a
good faith error on something like that
you could get a mistrial with without
prejudice and retry it
um that that would be the remedy if you
wanted it the defense I don't know if
they would depending on how the case
you're making a guess right the defense
lawyer would say hey I think we're going
to win anyway and not take it I have a
correction yeah at 2 45 PM the defense
made a verbal motion for a mistrial
without prejudice oh oh wow very wow
prosecution makes laundry list of
excuses over the state not providing
defense with high resolution drone video
judge warns prosecution he'd warned them
there would be a Day of Reckoning over
this drone video and then says he's not
going to make a decision now inclined to
see what the verdict is going to be on
the 15th the defense filed a motion for
a mistrial with prejudice which means
they cannot bring the charges back but
it seems like the defense is so upset
over the cheating that they're like just
do a mistrial we will do this over why
would they want to do would they do it
over would they have the same prosecutor
yeah it would be the same prosecutor but
you know their whole case now you have
their Witnesses on the record so you
they can't change their story they can't
be impeached you yeah you have all this
and then there's that guy who his
criminal record has all come out now
maybe you didn't have that the DUI
against instead of being dismissed maybe
that comes in so there's a lot of things
that you're going to try to bring in in
a do-over and all anybody can do is is
guests right and I think that so the
defense is squeamish now because usually
a longer deliberations means guilty oh
okay because people don't want to come
back quick from jury and convict right
because then it looks like you're just a
bad person like oh yeah you know we
heard the evidence 30 minutes guilty
boom you take longer but if it's not
guilty you come back right away now the
written house there's all the
speculation that there's a couple of
holdouts they're left-wing activists and
that it's going to be hung by two left
me activists nobody knows though is all
a complete and total guess as to do they
need this majority to quit or is it has
to be unanimous either way it has to be
Indiana's either way oh so if it's split
it's a mystery it's a mistrial and then
and then they go back and try it again
okay Will Chamberlain had some
interesting comments about this he said
earlier that quote pretty clear that
Rittenhouse lawyers are getting jittery
moving for a mistrial without prejudice
indicates a serious worry that a guilty
verdict is coming back and that they
want to get in front of it so that could
be a possibility here as well I don't
think guilty so here's the way you you
would game it out if you were you know
if you're a white born again you would
say okay if it already looks like the
jury is going to be hung right we don't
know if it's going to be hung because it
was 10 to guilty and two not guilty or
if it was 10 not guilty two holdouts
they're gonna hang it but you're
thinking you started gonna hang so then
why would you even take a choice that it
might be hanging because it's going to
be guilty or that they're going to
convince us two other jurors to to
change their vote to being guilty so
you're thinking the odds would just say
let's just do a redo and we have all
this information now that we can use but
they still filed a motion for missile
with prejudice and a verbal motion for
mistrial are both motions available to
the judge well one would supersede the
judge can do whatever he wants so the
initial reason they filed it the motion
with prejudice so there was that set of
questions where the prosecutor had said
this is your first time talking since
August 25th 2020. now there's this is
black letter law that you cannot make a
comment about a person exercising his or
her Miranda Right what does black letter
law mean oh it means it's not really up
for debate okay it just is if you take
the bar exam and you read that
transcript there's actually a right
answer now the prosecutor tried to say
well I wasn't commenting on his his uh
silence I was just saying that because
he was able to watch the whole trial he
could key up his story and you
technically can make that argument but
you can't say this is the first time
you've talked you can say you can skip
that line and say hey isn't it true Tim
that you've been sitting here for this
whole trial and you go yes well isn't it
true that you've watched everyone is
testifying you say yes you go so isn't
it true then that you know exactly what
you have to say in order to get the
outcome you want you can do that but no
yeah right exactly yeah you would say no
I'm here to tell the truth and there's
all this back and forth but the idea too
in the prosecutor is not very competent
Binger is not confident at all when you
when you're cross-examining you you just
give a person a yes or no answer you
don't let them elaborate like that he
you there's so many just basic tactical
blunders that he made but that would be
the idea because then he would say isn't
it true that you could come up with any
story you want you would say no I'm here
to tell the truth and then it doesn't
matter because you're just imposing your
narrative on the witness and
cross-examination which is the way it's
supposed to be you're you don't get to
tell your narrative on cross-examination
The Inquisitor gets to and everything
has to be a leading question yes or no
just keep it yes or no isn't that true
so fortunately Binger is incompetent
unethical and I I tweeted out even you
know quoting Michael Mouse that to be
black pill does to think that Binger is
going to beat us right yeah like that
these are unstoppable foes yeah yeah
they're clearly they're evil yeah but
yeah but you so the jury is deliberating
don't they know people outside are
screaming on megaphones of course the
jury should have been sequestered
they're not sequestered you know that
someone are you serious and someone I
know I didn't believe it myself someone
filmed the jury from their bus pickup
and the judge went well we'll just make
sure that doesn't happen again when we
deleted the footage and it's like what
yeah no and the jury's got to be
sweating bullets right
right and there's no mayor Garland's not
going to issue a memo saying that we
need to go after people who are trying
to tamper with the jury even though
that's how they get the mob for jury
tampering it's literally jury tamping uh
tampering happening here and they're
getting away with it so they're
definitely evil but they're also dumb
and that's what so that if you're
looking at this from a big strategic
perspective right and that's what makes
them dangerous is they don't have any
morality that that much we know but
they're dumb and they haven't been
through a crucible I don't know if you
saw Adam Schiff cry on The View over a
couple questions and I'm thinking they
they can't stand any kind of media
scrutiny so they are winning can you
explain something else to me because
like I always try to steal man like it's
something I understand like I'm thinking
it's me why would how would anyone as a
prosecutor tell the jury and and the
audience that who hasn't taken a beating
at one point in their life that seems
like such a bizarre statement to make
they said that yeah like what am I
missing
uh people make bad arguments oh okay is
it what it looks like okay yeah I want
to address what you were saying you know
look zombies have no morality and
zombies are stupid but when you get a
whole lot of them you're in trouble at
least figuratively because no one's ever
actually been attacked by zombies but
you get the point no they out and that's
that was strategically is they outnumber
us they're evil and they're dumb but
that's how you have to war game it out
yeah is you but the problem with
you know conservatives or whatever the
case is the people who are supposed to
counteract it is they constantly refuse
to accept that you're dealing with the
evil this isn't that they're not wrong
they're not making mistakes they're evil
right they want to like destroy people's
lives I was yeah I was just on a Rogan's
show and um I don't think it comes out
today a couple black comes out tomorrow
whatever but I said Chris Cuomo was evil
and Joe was like no man he's like he's
not evil look these guys are just doing
production they're not paying attention
and I said it's the banality of evil
Chris Cuomo pretended to be in
quarantine to trick people into thinking
he was locked down when he wasn't when
he was going to his private property and
got into a fight with some guy or verbal
altercation and I said it's evil to
willfully deceive the people yeah it's
lying it's called lying but but it's
more than lying we're talking about
people whose lives are being destroyed
by this and he's acting as an agent to
make sure they don't resist as their
businesses their homes their families
and everything everything's destroyed
I'm like it's evil it's tough because
this cell phone was built by slaves and
I I know that but I'm still I still
bought it and I still use it is that am
I evil yes
thank you Michael the honest truth
that's not why
but isn't it still the banality of evil
that we knew that the Foxconn Labs were
so horrifying people were committing
mass suicide and we were alike but we
accept this because we want it isn't
that the banality that we would just go
along with these horrifying systems and
the banality evil is more the idea that
evil doesn't come in the form that you
think it is a Charles Manson it was
based on Hera and its book where she
would examine these Nazis and they're
more like hey I just want to like keep
my job and I need to get excellent views
yeah but but hey look I just the phone I
need it for work
but Cuomo's mostly evil right but now
banality of evil would imply that he's
just like um hey I'm gonna get
vaccinated for my job and I'm gonna have
a vax and I'm gonna show my vaccination
pass to people and I'm just gonna kind
of cooperate because this is what I have
to do Ian actually had I think one of
the best responses because we were
talking about whether or not the NPCs
the zombie hordes are truly evil and so
I asked Ian I was like Ian are zombies
evil and he immediately was like uh well
in d d yes they are chaotic evil but
whether or not they don't have an
alignment anymore Ian but they made them
neutral yeah they're not neutral they
don't have an alignment whoa what is
happening the funny topsy-turvy do your
homework well the zombie Lord is evil I
know that well the zombie Lord has
sentience yes okay guys King I want to
talk to you about evil
I want to talk to all of you about
The Rittenhouse trial and what we can
see as reasonable mature adults evil did
you know that Gage gross kreutz in
January 2021 had a drunk driving offense
and the prosecutor said we'll make that
go bye-bye six days before the
writtenhouse trial let me show you here
from from New York Post sole survivor
has criminal past they say gross kreutz
28 was in court just six days before
writtenhouse's murder trial where he was
a star witness to have a recent drunk
driving charge dismissed on a
technicality
I wonder so weird yeah I mean we talked
about this a little bit when Rogan came
on I kind of went off and talked about
all of his criminal charges The Daily
Mail called him a career criminal but
this wasn't his first DUI this was his
second DUI now I don't know anyone who
had a DUI had a second one and was able
to get off of it when when the
consequences are so serious when when
you have a second DUI I mean I we could
look up exactly the the ramifications of
it but the first eui in some states they
take away your car they take away your
license and you face a a very long jail
term because of that a second one on a
long criminal record of domestic abuse
prowling trespass felony burglary two
counts of carrying firearms while
intoxicated on top of these two DUIs I
mean we're talking about someone who's
definitely not a upstanding citizen but
yet he's treated like some kind of
celebrity on Good Morning America which
he had his first interview on and I
think the Nerds want to nerd out about
some
you were just talking about how these
people are our NPCs they're zombies and
the question is are zombies evil as a
fifth edition Dungeons and Dragons yes
they are neutral Evil all right they
don't tend towards law or chaos they're
kind of in the middle evil but they're
definitely evil okay so so
yeah for context for people who don't
understand we're just making analogy too
you have all of these people who will
vote Democrat who will go along with
with lockdowns and mandates and
restrictions on civil liberties they'll
go along with the writtenhouse
prosecutor presenting false evidence and
they will just say I don't care what
happened I'm on their side no matter
what we call them zombies and then the
question was but is that evil or is that
just being a zombie Ian told us last
week that in d d zombies are evil but
Michael contested this and you've been
fact checked sir zombies are evil I also
think there's a difference between NPCs
and zombies though I think so too yeah
and because zombies are actually
actively hunting NPCs and this suggests
that they're neutral evil suggest that
they will betray the law at any moment
for their own self-serving purposes and
they'll also side with the law at any
moment for their own self-service
are Mindless yes don't have an opinion
on the law yeah you can I mean you can
get you know what is evil this evil
Inquirer intent does it require outcome
what if you're in good nature and that's
why I don't use
um and I really used to not use it but
my rhetoric has probably gotten a little
more fiery over the years I very rarely
see someone's evil almost never I used
to be the exact same way and I'd be very
philosophical like a lot of these people
are just not paying attention but when
we get to the point where Binger the the
prosecutor introduces fake evidence CGI
evidence uh commits of constitutional
violations defies the rulings the
problem is the judge let him get away
with it evil is rewarded but I don't
think that I agree with Mike but I think
NPCs aren't evil per se but the ones who
are running running the show are the
evil ones right right the Chris cuom was
evil yeah yeah Don lemon's evil the
Lemmings who watch CNN yeah they're just
Lemmings yeah they would fall off a
cliff they would literally if Chris
Cuomo told people to do anything they
would fall off a cliff to their own
detriment and if they were born in Idaho
they'd be watching fox in the vnp season
that right right exactly so they're just
following whatever they're told to do so
they're not real they're not evil
they're just mindless people who would
go off a cliff again if they had them
which is different but binger's evil uh
without question because the people who
are trying to Lynch a 17 year old are
evil the pedophile who got shot was evil
like pedophilia like I put that in the
evil list yeah and this guy I mean
it it was the most atrocious I want to
not get into the specifics because it's
so atrocious I don't think people want
to hear what he did to these children
right he didn't just it wasn't like he
was watching pornography he actually
assaulted a child more than a child I
think that's a big difference salt is
not strong enough we can't say atrocity
yeah yeah he committed atrocities
against children five of them 11 counts
ages 9 to 11. and there's no and there's
no the only reason he's allowed on the
street is because of our legal system
which is flawed if someone does that to
a child this person should never be
allowed to see the outside of a cell
children I'm kind of with you about I'm
reticent to call people good and evil
because the way especially the way D and
D works it's a scale from like yeah let
me reference the Bible real quick you
have a rating from one to a hundred evil
being one good being a hundred and
you're somewhere on that scale 78 say
every act you do maybe it's an evil act
might drop that from a 78 to a 74. and
then you might do a good act to a tone
and then you might do something horrible
like kill someone and it drops to a five
and all of a sudden but that does
so you're you're not right you might be
able to say right now what you've done
we think you're able but that doesn't
mean you're not capable of good should I
believe in God and Redemption and I
think that I mean I believe in original
sense I think we're all we all have evil
in us so let me ask you this question
though Ian if Reza oslano CNN eats human
brain is he a Canada I don't oh that's a
good question yeah if you played tennis
in your 20s but you no longer put Noah
Claire are you still a tennis player
well hold on but we're talking about
very serious actions I understand people
like I I would actually argue if you
played tennis
like you're a tennis player but
cannibalism is something very specific
Reza Aslan of CNN on TV ate human brain
is it fair to get it though it was given
to him by these this this Fringe sect of
like Hindu monks or whatever but how
could a human brain have anything to do
with CNN that makes no sense CNN did a
show about religions
but hold on does anyone address the
question is Reza ozon a cannibal even
though he's not eating human well the
the idea that goes to does your are you
defined by your worst moment right and
again that's why I don't like the to use
evil because if you're a lawyer you've
thought about this if you've defended
people charged with terrible things that
you think are you defined by your worst
moment and that's a question that
everybody has to rust with this
philosophical one so can you never not
there's even that joke that the guy said
he fornicated with the goat once and now
for the rest of the life he's a goat
fornicator
and my my belief generally speaking is
that there's a Redemption period that
actually almost everything well no no
hold on hold on I disagree okay
Rosenbaum
10 years 20 years it's been 15 years it
had been 15 years since those actions he
committed uh sorry is that the one who
assault the kids yes you don't come back
from that you don't come back but you
come back from eating human yes because
he didn't kill the human you didn't kill
a person all right what if you murder
someone are you a murderer yes yes
forever yes in my opinion if it's murder
I don't mean like drunk driving and why
not a cannibal like see this is it
important cannibalism is that bad in
this context but what I'm saying is what
we're basically saying is based on our
personal views of morality we're willing
to give someone Redemption and not call
them a name by their worst moment if if
someone murdered someone they're always
a murderer Alec Baldwin is always a
murderer's no longer a cannibal I don't
think any human brain like I said with
with stuff that happens with kids is a
little different I don't like to reduce
people to their to their lowest moment
okay right that generally speaking
that's not how I view Humanity because
my fundamental view is that we're all
whatever's in our hearts and Minds if
that were published to the world what
would that look like like right and then
he would say well that's the evil
thought that's different the actions are
different and there's a whole sliding
scale for this but my my view generally
speaking is that you don't hold you
don't define a person by their worst
moment with the exception again with you
know if you're a Serial child molester
you know that's a little bit different
than a guy who loaded up maybe something
a video or something that he shouldn't
have there could be a period of
redemption after that but in the family
is friendliest way I want to make sure
we stress that he was beyond that
Rosenbaum was committing atrocities
against children worst possible the
worst possible thing you could imagine
being done to a child that they have to
live with rather I would also say don't
Define people by their best moments yes
because a lot of people like Alec
Baldwin's done a lot of great work as an
actor but if he does some horrible crime
I don't want to be like well he's a good
guy
bad moment is and how good the good
moment is right if someone's like a
firefighter and then he like you know
gets into a bar fight and beats somebody
up I'm willing to let that slide if he's
saying I don't care about a bar fight
anyway yeah exactly yeah yeah I think
there's a sliding scale too because are
we talking talking about someone like
Henry Kissinger Jeffrey Epstein because
they're in a different realm of evil
yeah comparatively to of course you know
low-level criminals Petty criminals
arsonists there's a big difference
that's a good way if you think of every
action in your life is weighting the
scale of one to a hundred if you've done
a million things that have given you a
hundred and then you do one thing that
gives you a one it's barely gonna move
the needle to 99. like Henry Kissinger
is Satan he is absolutely evil
listen honey stop it
in the kitchen you like his his ideas on
limited War I don't want to derail but I
mean what what Kissinger has done
throughout his entire career uh propping
up China and and the Communists State
there deed industrializing the United
States bringing jobs over there putting
the current geopolitical situation
setting up Saudi Arabia with the petrol
dollar I mean the way that the world is
right now how broken it is can be
directly core correlated to Henry
Kissinger the man advises the pope he
advised presidents he advises
corporations he advised Obama Obama's
National Security adviser said he takes
his daily orders from Henry Kissinger
and Alabama has a lot of influence in
the Biden Administration so I I would
say he's still in charge he sat down
with Donald Trump Donald Trump was was
licking his boots all right those are
really good points I don't want to
derail though and I have a question for
uh cernovich
the deliberations in the Kyle
Rittenhouse trial have now gone on for
over two days
what do you think that means
well that's what I was talking about
earlier if I were his lawyer what I
think it would mean is that if you can
get a mistrial without prejudice you
want to roll the dice again because
you're only the only outcome for you at
that point is it's tending towards bad
if I had to guess I would say that
there's one or two holdouts to convict
it's the vast majority of people who are
not guilty a couple of activists got on
that jury and they're going to hang
because usually you hang the juror the
other way usually your your challenge is
getting one or two people usually need
two because one person is always going
to back down to vote not guilty and get
the retrial this I think is the opposite
because he's so clearly like if we were
the left and he were convicted my God
because he's so clearly not guilty is
not even up for a reasonable discussion
if they were to get a mistrial without
prejudice would they get a new jury yep
it'd be uh all over finding an untainted
jury at this point but on top of that do
they recall all the witnesses yeah every
you so what you do and this is why if
you're if you're writtenhouse's lawyer
you're thinking May and I have
indigestion things have been going on
for a long time looking like we're not
going to get in not guilty if we roll
the dice again we have every witness now
we know what they're going to say yeah
so we know what our opening argument or
closing our argument is going to be you
have the test now the judge knows this
yeah the judge when when they the
writtenhouse defense filed a motion for
mistrial with prejudice because it had
uh but they did that before
deliberations even started right but now
we're we're a day into deliberations and
they came back on day two and said we'll
take a mistrial with no Prejudice so the
judge has to know they're sweating yeah
no no he knows and the odds have changed
so the way things are going now you
think let's roll again we have all we
have all everybody on the record now all
the evidence that the prosecutor had had
we have it can only get better the
defense in the second trial so if I'm
them I'm thinking it can only get better
for us yeah if we retry this mofo it can
only get better for us there's a lot lot
of mistakes they made uh there's a lot
of things the defense defense they did I
think they did fairly well I think the
state screwed up royally but that means
the defense has all of that knowledge of
their screw-ups they know the state the
state's weaknesses and the things in the
stand that really screwed them up they
have that advantage and they can pull
the jury when there's a mistrial so they
can talk to the jurors who said well hey
you know why'd you think he was like oh
wow they can do that oh yeah yeah why
yeah one you can pull the jury yeah yeah
they can see what arguments work but
exactly and then you focus group that
wow yeah yeah so a lot of people you
can't do this in criminal trials because
you can't afford them but in big high
injury personal injury they do mock
trials and they bring in juries and then
they say well you know or they'll even
have like buttons where they're like if
you think something's really good like
you push the button and some animals
because this is where there's tens of
millions of dollars at stake and if it's
just your life you know it's just
unfortunate so if they have a mistrial
does he go back in jail is he out on
parole on whatever he was he was out on
bails
a bail okay they could talk to the jury
they could get a a reshot okay it would
only get better through defense so if
I'm them and I could get a missed trial
without prejudice I know that people are
going to second-guess me but I take that
in a second okay I gotta tell you if um
the reason why I don't think I could
probably ever be on a jury is that there
is almost almost no circumstance in
which I would say guilty okay can I can
I jump in here yeah no I'm not allowed
to say this so I'm going to tap dance a
little about it uh there's something
called grand jury and what grand jury is
is like I think 25 or 30 people you're
impaneled for two weeks and you all have
to sit in and this is where you get uh
charges put forward right like they say
a grand jury will die to hand sandwich I
said to them this part I can't say I'm
an anarchist I won't convict under any
circumstances they said too bad you're
on the grand jury I'm like all right now
that I'm under these circumstances I
have to work within the system it is
very easy I'm giving this advice to
everyone especially on drug charges
juries want to be led so if you are a
possibility of being on a jury and you
say to people look we have no duty to
convict do you really want to ruin this
kid's life because he had some leader
was selling some weed that's going to be
on your conscious then talk about
slavery and how I made this up
like you know they wouldn't convict
unslaved charges back in there they
probably didn't but I was pulling out of
my ass and you'd be amazed at how
receptive people are to letting people
walk when someone makes a coaching case
for them and when that D.A walks back in
the room and you say we're not returning
any charges they're baffled but all it
takes is that one person on that grand
jury to sway everybody else and make a
coaching argument but it's not just it's
not just that people want to be swayed
it's that many rnpcs a lot of people are
there like I don't want to be here I got
to go to work the game's on today but
they do want to do the right thing for
sure and your job is to tell them what
that is as a leader when you say we
should not return to name it so so my
point was if I'm on a jury and and they
say you know like here's a guy who was
in his home he defended himself and the
state says we think that he actually
intended to commit harm I'd be like
because I'm not I'm like very similar to
your uh ideology however I say almost
none because if I'm on a jury and it's
very very oh yeah yeah very clear-cut
like Rosenbaum I'd be like guilty guilty
guilty or there's cases where like if
someone like literally raped or killed
someone it's it's well it depends if
there's victimless yeah exactly I'm sure
I've heard stories about the free state
project whenever they have Gatherings
that whenever they find out someone has
jury duty they all celebrate and get
really happy because they know it's an
opportunity to nullify whatever laws
they don't believe in personally and you
know a lot of people they get the jury
duty to notice they're like oh crap I
don't want to do this they feel bad
about this but you have an opportunity
to raise your voice and actually make an
argument that could have severe
ramifications for the law on where you
live and there's a thing called the
victimless crimes do the research on it
do the homework on it because if there
isn't a victim there's no reason the
state should be going after individuals
and I will never convict on a drug
charge no matter what yeah the judge
could say if the state has proven their
case that this man was in possession of
Acts you must return a guilty verdict
and I'll say no I won't no you won't you
don't have to yeah when people give like
very addictive drugs to children I get a
little nervous because I'm pretty wide
open on drugs kids are different kids
are different that's why I say almost
because that I would say in the instance
of fentanyl if someone is giving
fentanyl to people and he knows they're
dying but that's poisoning them that's
not to give them drugs
yeah I mean that's but that's why it's
hard it's easy to say never nope nope no
no no no no Lydia that's not a drug
charge that's a murder charge that's
interesting that you consider fentanyl
especially in large doses a poison it's
I have noise again if I give you a soda
but it's really got arsenic in it
exactly arsenic's not a drug yeah
there's a victim this is different yeah
I in almost any circumstance where a
person chooses is I would probably not
convict so children are different
victims victimless crimes are almost a
guarantee alike this person was in
possession of this I'd be like I don't
care there's also informed consent so if
an event if if a person wants to take
fentanyl that is that person's right
it's his body it's his choice but it's
someone yeah they of course shouldn't
but if someone puts it in a substance
and the other person doesn't know about
it right that's a crime that's obviously
something that should be punished and
someone should be held accountable for
their individual actions I'll I'll put
it this way in questions of individual
choice
those kinds of Trials and I'm almost
never going you'd never get me to
connect on anything and this is a great
opportunity for everyone to Save a Life
not only that that's true but with Kyle
Rittenhouse you know why there's no
argument they could make in court to
convince me to convict I'm not saying
you can't convince me that Kyle was
wrong I certainly don't think he was
wrong I think that there's reasons he
shouldn't have been there for sure but I
believe he was defending himself and I
think there are a lot of issues at play
but the reason I would never convict
almost ever on a self-defense issue is
because it is better that 100 guilty
persons Go free than one innocent person
suffer yes
yeah I look I understand the risks I
understand the risks of releasing a
hundred guilty persons but I will not be
party to A system that imprisons the
innocent but the thing is releasing
guilty people is what happened he's
fighting off pedophiles and assailants
yeah
yep yeah Rosenbaum was released that day
yeah well so there's a question about
that some people have said he was in a
mental hospital
but some people are saying they can't
find the records of that and they
haven't found the documentation proving
that some people say it was a jail but
again it's still very unclear either way
my view is like I think
it's it's shocking to me how inhuman our
legal system has become and I've always
been this way Tim sort of yeah yes I
agree with you to a great degree but
when we had a very very uh small when
our communities were very very small and
everyone knew each other it was very
different judge judge Smith was not set
in Walter's kid to prison for the rest
of his life because he was in possession
he's gonna be like aren't you Bill
aren't you Walter's kid what are you
doing coming down here with this stuff
if I see you I see your dad down at the
pub I'm gonna tell him what for we're
giving you probation or whatever today
the cop walks over says I don't know you
I don't care tell the judge big city
what happened problem with density when
the prosecutor if the prosecutor to find
evidence of of Innocence would they
would they still go for the guilty
verdict or are they do they have a duty
to be like well that's called the Brady
violation so that that again goes to
evidence uh the prosecutor has a duty so
there's I don't want to go too far on
the weeds with you guys but there are
two different ways to do this one is you
have constitutionally the prosecutor has
to disclose any evidence that could go
to guilt or mitigation at sentencing so
if they know you're in a set they have a
duty to do it some states have which is
called the open file law so if you're a
prosecutor you just have to give your
file to the defense there that way you
can't say well I don't think this piece
of evidence is really going to be what's
called exculpatory evidence uh it's not
exculpatory so you don't even give them
that choice and most people like me
Advocate open are most people who are
civil Libertarians Advocate open files
if you're gonna whatever you have you
have to get rid of the fence right
because your duty is to do justice
that's the the myth is that you know if
you're a lawyer and you're suing me in a
litigation case your job is only to your
client you don't know anything to me but
the idea is prosecutors have a duty to
quote unquote do justice it's all fake
you know what you're saying though is is
is always been like it's always been bad
yeah but but you know what's sad to me
prosecutors are supposed to they're
aren't they supposed to seek Justice
that's the point of prosecution right
then they have grand juries which is
okay we're gonna impanel regular people
to see if they agree we should bring
charges and it's all broken yeah well
there's another aspect to this when
people go to jail they come out way
worse jail is usually a university for
criminals where they learn how to do
more criminal and activities and network
network with other people uh and and
they come out of that place a lot worse
than they came in and they become more
destructive towards society and it's a
it's a cycle where they keep going in
and out yes in and out and and the
system not only tortures them not only
uh you know deprives them and and
especially with the January 6th uh
people who are were sent to Jail the
inhumane
situations that they're put in cells
that are flooded with sewage uh denied
basic medical attention denied even
proper food getting beaten by guards
we're talking about a system that
corrupts a human being and robs them of
their life so so and again there are
some really bad people out there that
they deserve punishment but a lot of
times what they get in the prison system
is not that and I think it's very
unfortunate that when you talk about
having better prison conditions for
prisoners a lot of people who are
conservatively like well they shouldn't
have done this throw lock them up throw
away the key God help you if uh whatever
this Prosecutor's name decides you
should be throwing away the king well
they're in jail right now they're called
the January 6th I don't I don't like the
idea of deserve punishment I don't like
a a justice system that is actually just
a punishment or retribution system I
look at people who do bad things and say
how can we make them not do a bad thing
in the future and then welcome them back
into the warm loving bosom of society
but then you guys were just saying that
you define people by the lowest moment
though right some people yes and some
people go to prison right no no but
that's the whole idea though is in a way
you you have to choose do you want do
you want retribution do you want
Redemption how do you find Redemption
yeah but I'm not saying it's it's a
zero-sum game some people are not worthy
of redemption and I I think we can try
or we can say of people like Rosenbaum
who committed atrocities we say this guy
should probably be locked up forever
well that would happen when the someone
like that does get released well that's
why if you asked me and other people
like uh you know people have thought
about these issues we send way too many
people to prison but we don't send
violent criminals away long enough right
exactly right yeah yeah in both ways
yeah it's like we got to sharpen the
curve you know the very violent get more
time and most people get left the Q Anon
you know Q Anon uh Sean is gonna do did
more time than that well he got charged
for 41 months uh as of today
well in addition we got 51 months
because 10 was time serving Solitaire
confinement right it was in solitary
yeah 10 months no they completely broken
well torture there's no way yeah
solitary confinement is torture yeah so
check this out so so we do have this
story this is from Daily Mail I have no
excuses it was indefensible contrite
Shaman Jacob Chancellor ascendants to 41
months in prison for his role in the
capital rights 41 months and I will tell
you this there's one reason why he got
41 months because he wore horns and I
think I'm joking I'm not joking
seriously it was iconic photography it
was iconic that's what the prosecutor
was arguing that he's a symbol of the
Insurrection yep these so there were
people there who were shoving against
cops who were violent and attacking and
that I get arrest them charge them you
committed a crime but there were people
who bumbled in who were walking around
doors opened by the police and many of
these people are getting charged but
it's worse than that it's the torture
that's going on in the jails for any one
of these individuals it's wrong and it's
the P it was that woman I think in
Alaska right the feds Raider home the
overreach on this is insane it's the
expansion of the capital police
Nationwide what the Biden
administration's doj has been doing
across the board has been nightmarishly
corrupt but I want to make sure we focus
on the torture how do you get a guys
wearing orange and he bumbles and he
goes and then he leaves for 41 months
51. there was yeah no no I guess the
prosecutor wanted 51 he got 41 and he'll
get time served for the 10 months he did
did you hear what Enrique tario said no
Enrique tario uh the chairman of The
Proud boys is in jail because he
confessed to to tearing down a black
lives matter uh banner and then burning
it and I think he got only a few months
six months six months and he said his
his self fills with sewage he's like
basically he was he being abused by
guards or was that him who said that he
there was a letter written by him that
came out that people could read and they
could see what he's going through right
now I don't want to put words in his
mouth he I think he he said it very
eloquently in his letter and I think
people should read it to bring attention
to this but six months for for that
charge compare that to all the other
rioting and crazy stuff that we know the
FBI has drones coverage of exactly
goes to a riot in Kenosha with a gun
he's not legally allowed to possess I
think by uh I'll say this to you Michael
I believe he has the right 2 the
constitutional right the human right to
but for our statute reasons and now
we're just we're arguing law enforcement
he wasn't allowed to have it what
happens the prosecutor instructs the
detectives not to execute a signed surge
search warrant against his phone he gets
Char drunk driving charges dismissed
just before the trial and he's getting
no charges when they know he lied to the
police that's obstruction they know his
gun he was not allowed to have concealed
because his permit was invalid no
charges
but Enrique tario well he vandalized
something now hey look vandalism is bad
you shouldn't tear down someone's banner
and burn it it's theft of property and
destruction right and it's
disproportionate and this also speaks to
this kind of uh ridiculous idea of
equality before the law which has never
existed and can never exist because
everyone knows it's an absolute given
that a district attorney will cut a deal
with someone who's lower on the totem
pole in the hopes of getting a better
person so if there was equality before
the law people would be treated and
prosecuted equally but they are
perfectly willing and able on a daily
basis say we know you committed these
crimes you're getting away with it just
as long as you cooperate with us you
think that if everyone was treated
equally under the law that inevitably
everyone that gets a certain position of
power would do something illegal and be
taken down and it would just the system
just couldn't function like the CIA is
an illegal it's its whole purpose is to
do illegal things in secret I I don't
think the system is in a position to
enforce itself you know I just had this
tweet today like so the Supreme Court
has to go through the Senate right and
for confirmation so it's basically like
asking prisoners to choose their own
Corrections Officers are they going to
pick Corrections offers that are going
to restrict their freedoms or are they
going to pick the CEOs and let them do
whatever the heck you want and that's
exactly what you see with the sentence
and the Supreme Court where the Supreme
Court gives them basically a blank check
to do whatever they like to be fair the
president
you know sure of course nominates them
yeah and then it has to go to the senate
for confirmation so they don't just get
to choose whoever they want they have to
agree and say We'll accept it right but
they are giving the rubber stamp they're
not going to give the rubber stamp on
someone historically speaking who's
going to tell them you at Congress can't
pass whatever laws you want yeah but
also we have way too many laws we have
way too much of a bureaucracy according
to Harvard University Professor Harvey
silvergate he estimates that on average
the American each day commits three
felonies a day
[Laughter]
three felonies a day uh Harvard
University Professor Harvey silvergate
uh came out with uh well this is over
criminalization I do there's been
there's been like a lot of research on
it so let's just say for example you
dump your gray water tank in a parking
lot they could come up with an
environmental regulation violation into
that and turn something that would be
you know at most civil offense with a
fine and they could cook that up so
there's laws about junk mail there's
laws about all kinds of things that
would really surprise you and is all
about what they can get away with and
and you could be like you know it's like
a regular old high school teacher who
takes an RV out to the desert to cook
some blue math and all of a sudden you
get the DEA TV show made about you the
TV show is that did that say your
average person commits three felonies
per day uh yeah so that would mean that
some people might do nine and the two
other people might do zero yeah
I mean lying on your resume is
technically wire fraud because you oh
yeah yeah you commit fraud because
you're trying to get money or a thing of
value from an employer you transmit it
via Interstate Commerce via the Internet
so that's technically wire fraud wow I
wasn't that sheath underwear model as
they used the body double
they got this really fit little person
yeah I love it
no that's why lawyers are always you
know paranoid because you realize that
if they want to get you yeah like the
way I describe it to people is if they
want to get you they will but don't give
them your head yeah and there's a lot
because people do a lot of Reckless
things so for example if I I didn't even
go to DC on January 6 because in the
back of my mind I said I bet you they'll
cook up something they'll cook up
something against me if I'm even there
because that's the lawyer in me and then
you know a lot of people they just
walked in well technically those people
didn't violate the law because trespass
requires that you know that you're not
supposed to be there you get a warning
yeah and if you're if you were just some
like Maga rube who came out from Ohio
because you believe in Q Anon you you
don't you don't know if you're not
pushing forward you're just like
following the police opened the door for
them took selfies with you so they
didn't actually break the law because
they didn't have notice that they
weren't supposed to be there it doesn't
really matter so they will or like they
did with James O'Keefe it sounds like
they're trying to cook up something
against him
even though he didn't do anything
illegal but they'll cook it up well you
you add three fellows three felonies a
day with the constant surveillance that
happens on the average American with
almost everything being tracked trace
and database with the FBI using their
counter-terrorism division to
investigate parents who go to PTA
meetings when you add all of that up you
have a recipe of disaster you have
essentially the KGB going after
political dissidents who of course
disagree with the current political
structure and dare challenge challenge
The Narrative that they're trying to
invoke onto everyone and look
conservatives were the Law and Order
people forever like I was always a like
you can go back I wrote I was writing
about this stuff 20 years ago this is
just my wheelhouse and conservatives
never gave a [ __ ] you know or never gave
a crap and now suddenly they care and
they're like oh we're being unfairly
treated no you're not yeah this is what
happens to people charged with Federal
offenses this is what happens to
everyone oh the January 6 people are
being treated different of the writers
dude everybody who goes to that federal
system gets cooked they say you can beat
the you can beat the rap but you can't
beat the ride they'll grind you down
destroy your life that's what they do to
everybody infinite money but yeah it's
your tax money and there's that a line
about how a liberal is a conservative
who's been arrested but a conserved as a
liberal who's been arrested but a
liberal is a con hold on a liberal is a
cons a conservative is a liberal who's
been mugged and a liberal is a
conservative who's been arrested okay
yeah okay what happens if you've been
mugged and arrested because I've been
both have you I've been I think you're a
moderate I've just been around yeah
yeah yeah I was a a guy well so a guy
tried mugging me and I just laughed and
like he was so a guy comes up next to me
he's like six six six seven he's this
tall blonde dude and he's and I was in
Lincoln Park and I'm crossing the street
and he's like hey how's it going man
how's it going how's it going and I was
like good good and he goes awesome
awesome so why don't you give me the
money that you have give me the money
you have right now because I got a knife
on me and I want to do the right thing
and you want to do the right thing and
we don't got to get things bad and I
started are laughing and then I was like
yeah okay I don't have any money and he
goes you think you think I'm stupid you
think I don't know and so I pulled out
my empty wallet and I'm like here's my
no money and I put it back as I'm
walking I'm like not facing I'm just
keep walking and he's like I told you I
have a knife and I know you got your
money in your shoe and I started
laughing again we crossed the street and
we walked about a half block when all of
a sudden a cop grabs them like a plain
clothes anti-crime cop slams him up
against a wrought iron fence and screams
not in my town true story I'm not
kidding and then two beat cops run up
and they said apparently that they had
gotten like a report they saw the guy so
when he went up to me and tried shaking
me down but my attitude in Chicago has
always been like you know maybe it's
from being depressed in that City you
can't shake me down I'm just like yo
it's Chicago the high school fights that
were near my neighborhood ended with
gunshots you come up to me and tell me
you want money and I'm like this is not
the worst thing I've ever run from but
uh um I I wanted to I wanted to get into
the the FED overreaching all the stuff
because um we briefly mentioned James
O'Keefe guys I got a conspiracy theory
for you yes you ready for a conspiracy
theory conspiracy yeah I think you will
agree with me on the plausibility of
this conspiracy Alex is a Fed no um
James O'Keefe was investigating the FBI
so they rated him to try and seize the
evidence yes let me lay out my case oh
this is the new brainer the F right the
FBI raids James O'Keefe and project
Veritas and uh James his uh himself and
his home and his journalists they claim
it's over some diary that he turned over
to the law enforcement a long time ago
so this is what are they searching for a
diary he gave away already okay within
an hour or so of the raid the New York
Times calls for comment on some of these
journalists meaning someone tipped off
the New York Times
information electronic devices were
seized from James O'Keefe privileged
legal Communications were then leaked to
the New York Times it is widely believed
the FBI were leaking privileged
Communications to the New York Times the
New York Times stated that in those
Communications James O'Keefe was
discussing with his lawyer the extent to
which they could undercover record
federal law enforcement on October 20th
I believe it was an FBI whistleblower
sent documents to the Republicans
outlining how Merrick Garland was using
counter-terror tactics against parents
right the FBI must have found out and
this is my theory my hypothesis that
they had a leaker within the within the
bureau and that James O'Keefe I believe
they knew someone was communicating with
him but they didn't know what he was
given yeah yeah so they said we can't
let him release this so they rated him
under false pretext seized his
Communications activists within the
bureau said give it to the New York
Times and Destroy them that's my theory
I would even add that they probably were
the ones that gave him the diary in the
first place since this diary was going
around round and they didn't expect yeah
they didn't expect them to give it to to
law enforcement which project Veritas
did they didn't run with the story and
uh I just think they were extremely
desperate this is
this area at this point I don't think
this all makes perfect sense to me like
the fact that this got leaked when it
did the fact that they raided his house
the fact that he didn't even have the
diary but they assumed he would because
I guess that's what they would have done
if they'd been in his position this is
not a conspiracy theory to me this just
sounds to me like what happened in
October so I don't know when the leak
happened so this is a correction Fox
news reports and October 20th internal
email from the FBI's criminal encounter
Terror divisions released Tuesday by
House Republicans instructed agents to
apply the threat tag edu officials to
all investigations and assessments of
threats directed specifically at
education officials could it be and this
is we will all issue an update in
correction it wasn't that the FBI
whistleblower set the information on the
20th what if this FBI whistleblower went
to Veritas first
following the raid by the FBI earlier
this month The Whistleblower then
brought it to the Republicans
interesting
I think the FBI went after James O'Keefe
because they were scared that O'Keefe
had information on them and I will
stress the New York Times said in the
legal Communications that Veritas was
asking about the extent to which they
could secretly record FBI agents
yeah I think this is this is legit dude
I mean it's still conspiracy I got to
say it because there's no no evidence or
well there's some I guess you could call
evidence but there's no proof in any way
so we're still theorizing but I mean
James knows that's what the FBI does
James would know didn't they they in in
James might no when they did they set up
uh the whole what was it the Michigan
Governor yeah yeah the FBI plainly like
I don't know if they admitted to it or
what but they were like forced causing
that to happen you have and it was
before social media if this was 20 years
ago all of this would sound ridiculous
and crazy well now there's enough
evidence in a paper trail that people
are like all right this is plausible
well 20 years ago we had the FBI scandal
with the 1993 World Trade Center uh
bombing which also put them in a very
questionable situation so when you look
at the history of the FBI colored tell
probe uh and and all the other things
that they have done there's a long
history of doing things that were
absolutely illegal in the name of
fighting the law right so this is not
nothing new what what the FBI has been
up to throughout their entire existence
anyway
this is scary and and uh nightmarish
reality you know it's like uh it's like
we were in The Matrix the whole time you
know you're talking about how 20 years
ago we went to figure this out but the
internet basically for lack of a better
term red pilled everybody yes and now
they're all watching it happen from the
outside like oh dear Lord this is
horrifying yeah yeah I feel like the
Humanity's been under the boat since the
beginning and then the founding fathers
were like yo the the war they didn't
actually well Washington fought but that
sacrifice to kind of get us out from
under the boot but at what point did
they they all sacrificed they all did
each and every one of Franklin's song
joined the British oh of course they
sacrificed they they they they staked
there what did they say their their
blood their treasure and their sacred
honor or whatever there was a one
founding father's wife was taken
prisoner to be used in a prisoner
exchange a good majority of their homes
were under British occupation
mothers man just think about this the
signers the Declaration of Independence
who who sat down and could have just
went guys it's attacks it sucks but I
want to make sure my kids have food so
I'm not going to war and I will I will
throw it to Mel Gibson in one of the
best movies ever the Patriot where he
says is that the one here's with the
beaver the beaver no no the Patriot is
it's a long movie about him getting
revenge for the British soldiers killing
yourself okay
amazing movie and he's in South Carolina
he's in I think Charleston and he says
if you're asking me if I think taxation
without representation is wrong I agree
with you but if you are asking me to go
to war with England I say no and then
the British go to his house seeking
Rebels soldiers he's tending Aid to all
of them and his son was a writer for the
for the American revolutionaries so he's
like who is this man who are these
orders and then Mel Gibson's one of his
kids got a bunch of kids runs to try and
save the older brothers being arrested
and the the British officer shoots and
kills him Mel Gibson then uses his rep
like his uh American frontier War
training and goes on like a one-man
another one man he's like a group of
militiamen and he goes and starts
raiding uh the British but anyway I
digress that that that was an excellent
scene where you see a guy who doesn't
want to fight he doesn't want to go to
war
then I think back to the founding
fathers and what really happened they
all said from Young ages of like what 26
to like like 50s or whatever I will say
to the king I declare war on you and you
know what's funny you know what's really
funny and I say funny and not in the
hallway they knew they believed we'd
lose the founding fathers thought war
with Britain would never play off and
they would lose but the French
intervention saved us so these were guys
who were like I am so pissed off at them
quartering in our homes taking our
belongings telling us we can't defend
ourselves that I am willing to say I
will fight you and lose even if it means
my children and at the time England had
the biggest military in the world they
were the biggest might they were the
biggest power and uh that movie along
with Braveheart tells a very similar
story yeah absolutely has your blood
pumping and motivates you and it really
shows you the larger consequences of
what is routine in human history and
it's not an exception to the rule it is
the rule and the other thing that
they're not taught in a high school
civics class is how what a huge
percentage of the American population
were loyalists that's right that they
wanted nothing to do with this nonsense
were loyal British subjects shut the f
up George Washington leave us alone
you're making we're not revolutionaries
this is crazy so Victory is never a
function of persuading the majority
they're always going to follow the
leaders so I've read I've tried to do a
lot of I've done a decent amount of
research not a historian probably people
know better than me on the percentages
of
so yeah I've looked into it there's a
famous
um misconception where I think it was
Ben Franklin someone said a third are
loyalists a third are uh you know one
Independence and a third one to be left
alone but that's not actual numbers so I
looked I looked it up and the best
assessment I could find is that the
plurality uh wanted nothing to do with
anyone the plurality said shut up and
leave me alone and go away the next
largest group was in like the 30
percentile which said we want
independence and then in the 20 High
20th you know percentages were people
saying long live the king yeah all that
mattered was those who actually cared
the so the people who are uninitiated
said leave me alone abstained the
Revolution won the vote basically and
the other question about this is really
interesting when it came to voting on
whether to clear Independence a lot of
colonists were they were British they
all considered themselves British they
said by what Authority do you declare
independence in the name of our state
yeah they said who elected you
there and say you're a representative of
a free state of Virginia they just did
this they were like ad hoc pop-ups of
people being like we hereby we hereby
declare and then they sent the letter to
the king and the King was like but
people need to understand is the
Revolution was over 20 years the
regulars the British regulars were
coming here and getting into conflicts
and doing right control and getting shot
at and shooting back for for decades so
it wasn't just one day they said we
hereby declare independence here's a
letter and then the king said send in
the troops the troops were there they
were fighting and then within I think it
was like 1865 is when sentiment started
rising and we started seeing conflicts
1765. and then 1776 is when they're like
we are now asserting our independence
outright over 20 years this process took
place and then it was what another
decade or so before the Bill of Rights
you're right so it was a lot but it's
also funny when it's like the king gets
the Declaration he's like that's it I'm
setting in the troops like one month
later because he got away from us across
the Atlanta but check this out I talk
about this quite a bit
they all gather uh so so all these
founding fathers are sending letters to
each other and it takes a few weeks for
the letter to arrive in Virginia and
then to go back so the communication
around Independence is taking years they
have their their Continental Congress
they have their meetings and they say
okay we we're going to send a letter to
the king with our List of Demands
because they sent demand letters first
several how long did it take to get back
to the to the king three months by sale
then the king responds three months
later so six months for one question
yeah yeah one question and then a year
goes by and then I I'm like I'm thinking
I've talked about how funny it is you
know you know he's like uh Thomas
Jefferson says we hereby declare
independence ha ha we Fold It Up hand it
to the guy he gets on his horse he rides
to the boat everyone goes back to work
they go farm and they forget all about
it and then a year later a boat arrives
and they're like look big British
vessels are coming and they're angry
with us for some reason oh yeah that
letter
God damn it Hancock it's like it's like
no no Thomas Jefferson is like he's like
did I send the letter last night I was
drunk
I was with Sally in the barn the
regulars show up they're bombarding the
coast and they're like remember that
night a year ago we all got drunk and
we're like I think we should be into
Brandon you're you're I'm gonna write a
letter yeah you write a letter to the
king you tell him and they all sign it
they're like cheers I can't even read
your signature wait you actually mailed
it that was supposed to be a joke we
were just letting up steam right right
right you're supposed to not send it you
write the letter but don't send it yeah
that's therapy their recession I'm just
imagining the king like three months
later gets the Declaration of
Independence and he's like they've
they've already been acting as an
independent country for three months you
know so then he's like okay I guess you
know go quell the Revolution and then
he's like what a coincidence this would
be dated the same day as Independence
Day that's right that was the weirdest
part that was the weirdest part you know
um my understanding is an independence
day was July 2nd
right nice yeah why did we choose that I
don't remember there's like this this
like trivia thing they say did you know
the signing was the second but it wasn't
until like they didn't have to wait for
a couple signers or something I don't
remember I think it was like they mailed
it out uh you know on the fourth or
whatever or something like that so I
don't know if that's true but I remember
reading there was a quote from like John
Adams where it's like July 2nd will be
the day that America declared
independence since July 4. so we have
the boot on the neck now kind of right
in the metaphor is it like the global
banking system and we're like we will
use Bitcoin and all crypto and that's
our way of saying we don't respect your
Authority King George yeah I would say
so for sure not using Fiat money yeah I
think people need to realize that as
much as we can talk about the founding
fathers saying like hurray and then
taking up arms we're not in that era
anymore you know first of all we're
joking about the time gap between
sending a message now you can literally
be like yo we declare independence
anything's trigger it all happens so
everything's ready to go like EMF your
phone yeah everybody starts to trigger
fifth generational Warfare is the most
important point
the liberty-minded individuals whatever
you want to call this group have been
winning because we've been very
persuasive and peaceful when black lives
matter rioted black lives matter lost
tons of support among the politically
uninitiated when we when we start
winning hearts and minds and change the
culture that's how we actually win and
you don't win by freaking people out
with violence violence is wrong so what
did what
what it empowered the federal government
to create a national capital police
force and torture people right and you
get 80 million people going like oh no
an Insurrection and these politically
uninitiated buy into it so I often tell
people there's a there's a funny episode
of Frasier I saw a long time ago I don't
watch Frasier but it was when I was a
kid where something happens where um
Frazier is is sitting down for coffee he
gets up someone takes his seat he gets
angry and says this is my seat I was
sitting here and the guy says shove off
Frasier having a bad day grabs him and
throws him out of the scene yeah very
angry so the guy comes back one day with
like a neck brace and he's like I'm
suing you because you accosted me and
then Fraser's like oh no it's a big
lawsuit at the end of the episode he's
at the cafe trying to apologize to the
guy I could be getting the show wrong
with the gist of it is here he's trying
to apologize to the guy saying look I
shouldn't have done that too I'm really
really sorry please drop the suit and
the guy says no and then Niles Frazier's
brother gets up in between and says you
listen here you cretan you don't do that
you know to my brother are you imbecile
and so the guy says no no you listen to
me and then pokes his chest lightly and
then Niles goes and falls over and slams
into a table full of like silverware and
he goes counter suit countersuit and
then the guy drops his lawsuit the point
of that story is Niles goes to federal
prison no the guy attacked him he was
like I didn't do anything and they're
like we all saw you touch him you pushed
him so when you look at uh what's going
on with antifa violence
we might be upset that the feds aren't
charging these people but rest assured
regular Americans saw all of that and
one by one they started figuring out
what was going on now the media
narrative was strong and a lot of people
didn't realize the truth about the
Rittenhouse case but now we're seeing
The Young Turks we're seeing Chris Hayes
we're saying Chris Hayes said in all
likelihood he said I've been looking at
the case and and it looks like an
acquittal in all honesty yeah wait this
just because he's predicting acquittal
doesn't mean he thinks the guy's not
good no no I'm not saying he said right
now is not guilty I'm saying his
attitude is now he's gonna get acquitted
versus he's just you know like he's put
like it's a lightning on the narrative
and conspirin said I was wrong about
what happened okay progressives are
tweeting I didn't realize what had
actually happened so the more we are
persuasive the more we're correct and
the more that the corporate press is uh
dishonest because if there's a big
asymmetry I make this point all the time
if I tell you Tim my friend like 10
truths and One Lie those are not equal
weight it's about if the LIE is this
egregious when there's this kid on trial
who's 17 years old who's crying and then
you're laughing at his PTSD that's right
so I think there are a lot of I think
most people want safety security peace
they want to live their lives they want
to pursue their goals and they're not
really interested in politics and so
when they see the mainstream media that
corporate press say X Y and Z they say
yeah yeah x y and z i get it but then
one day X Y and Z don't equal one two
and three and they start getting
confused yes and it keeps piling on and
piling on and piling on but when you get
a January 6 that reinforces the The
Narrative from the corporate press from
the cathedral The Establishment so we
need to make sure if we tell if we if we
are saying 10 things and we are all
honest individuals trying our hardest
but we get one wrong people will say oh
they talk they made some bad predictions
but the stuff they said I found out to
be true the media is an inversion of
this yes they say 10 things and nine
things are wrong and people finally get
fed up and say this is BS they're lying
to me and then they say I come to you
for a solution yeah so we were talking
about how you would weight something
like a moral weight whether someone does
something bad and one and Luke brought
up Henry Kissinger and I was gonna say
one of the things that we should take
into account is whether or not this is a
pattern and I would say that this is the
same case with the media if they are
making a pattern of lying to us
egregiously about everything all the
time then they decide maybe they might
throw in a truth every now and then yes
we can say you are full of nonsense so
what ends up happening those uninitiated
individuals who aren't paying attention
are starting to ask questions about
whether gas is so high why they can't
buy turkeys because the price of turkey
is double and why are you telling me
this is a good thing right right oh this
is a rich people problem oh yeah and
then what happens a truck driver in New
Jersey wins his election against the
incumbent Democrat after only spending
153 bucks because we're getting the
point where people will elect a ham
sandwich over and establish this also
happened with Dave ball when he took out
Eric Cantor the House Majority Leader at
the time that no one saw coming when was
that when was that that was when was
that that was uh during the Obama
Administration I'm sure Canter yeah I
gotta I gotta sneak out guys I gotta
have a birthday dinner happy birthday
happy birthday man thank you thanks for
coming by how old are you is that public
knowledge 44. congratulations you got we
got you a cake you got to take the
birthday cake with you 100 can we show
the cake please do I don't have it it
says at least you tried oh no no no no
no I bought I bought the kids enjoy your
retirement yeah I bought the cake it
should be in the in the refrigerator
yeah show it I'm gonna have to grab it
you got any plans
but you know just you put the camera on
Mike it's his birthday and grab the cake
and walk it right over to him it's a
nice kick this is Mike cernovich shout
out to America for thinking of the cake
the very thoughtful thank you Luke's a
very thoughtful guy well thank you for
coming and being a part of the show and
I bet you probably have a lot of lessons
you've learned throughout the years
you've been very prolific on Twitter
we could light it too I don't know if
anyone has a lighter it looks really
good though I don't have one on me oh
that's cool just hand it to him take it
pick it up birthday hold it up show the
camera
you got him oh we could have lit it that
would have been fun I still have good
long shots it was good time bro thanks
for having me thanks for coming man
happy birthday go good there at a beer
garden I think oh nice yeah I've been
one of those in years well we're gonna
we're gonna jump over to Super chats out
yeah
you're not a prisoner right on we'll
take uh uh I'm sure there's a lot of
people who are eager to get questions in
for you but if you got there's a couple
for me I'll hit them real quick and then
yeah forget it yeah let's do it maybe
but I gotta find them that's the
challenge
we'll hit him next time thanks guys
everybody thanks so much
I probably can't find them fast enough
for you but you know just do your thing
and uh you know we'll do our thing and
be able to love psychically
why is no one talking about Jolene yeah
yeah no I know I know that should be
I've talked about as much as they were
in a house case or more or more
absolutely more yeah
thanks guys thanks all right man thanks
for coming all right we'll just we'll
just start with the super tips like
normal yeah and uh we'll just we'll just
carry on through the night with Mr
Michael malice yes we only have one
Michael now not only now we can say Mike
again instead of uh uh last name
cernavich and Malice
all right so we got here
oh we didn't even talk about the locals
thing yeah we should go into this we'll
do that on this bonus episode
I brought up um why don't we talk why
don't we just I brought up like a couple
weeks ago that let's talk about it
basically the Dave Rubin sold you out
and all the locals people buy this is a
deep there's a couple tiers to this
um
that he basically got a bunch of people
like hey come join my new patreon I'm
gonna do it right you can trust me No
One's Gonna ban you because I have the
keys all these people signed up and then
he was like and then he sold it to
another company now they have the keys
he doesn't have the keys anymore so he
kind of misled people that was when I
said that's my whole thing about it kind
of sold you out so so I have a lot to
say about this we're real sorry real
quick the context is Dave Rubin started
local as a subscription platform he
recently sold it to rumble I don't know
the full details on what he got for it
got stock and Rumble according to his
announcement video so I I hate when
people online are like explain yourself
or how are you friends with this person
I always usually block them or ignore
them it's different when someone is
friends with me and I know them and and
so on and so forth so because it's you
guys and we're all friends I've hung out
with Lydia one and one hunger team
one-on-one yeah uh Luke and I are
basically cousins because of our views
and her backgrounds and Ian you and I
never hung out one-on-one we've had
pretty intense conversations so I'm
perfectly receptive to something like
that happening here's the story with why
I'm at locals but I'm happy to be at
locals I was on patreon and I was
unhappy with patreon for a couple of
reasons one is the bonus thing I had was
like a Facebook Michael Mouse group but
then I'm at the risk of getting zucked
at any minute right number one that
happened Dave Smith who some of you guys
know really very failed comedian they
zucked his very failed career they
zucked his uh Facebook group for his
fans they just vanished it overnight so
that was an issue I had with patreon and
number two is I didn't like how patreon
also vanishes people overnight ideas to
learn something some other people Carl
Benjamin yeah Sargon one night you're
gonna wake up and your revenue is gone
Ruben calls me up I was the second
person he called after Bridget fantasy
and I also think it's important if I'm
taking money from people or if anyone is
to be transparent about it absolutely so
this was the advantages I had with
locals one is if I had an issue I knew I
could talk to Dave right away right me
and him have a close relationship I'm
not just gonna wake up and it's gonna be
deleted two he was gonna promote it so
that's gonna encourage people to support
me and three I own the content there now
I it's kind of a Community I don't post
that much on that there's some exclusive
content the primary thing is it's like I
use it like a patreon and also it's not
beholden to Facebook right so when he
sold this to rumble none of my data went
anywhere it's still my dad and always
has been my data that I could take with
me so same thing is true for patreon
well I fine but the point is the there's
no upside for me of being patreon that's
being on patreon and these are some very
specific upsides that I can have for
being on locals so I don't see what the
issue is you think it's like the least
worst subscription-based service right
now yeah and I had some big benefits
from doing it I'll explain my my
perspective on this and why I'm not a
fan uh and I think the easiest way to
explain to people is that I actually am
rather economically left libertarian
okay when patreon as a massive Silicon
Valley you know VC funded Enterprise
emerges and starts uh coordinating and
colluding to destroy people's careers
and they did because we saw the after
patreon banned certain individuals they
started going after any company editor
subscribe star was a good example they
had their access to online Financial
Services terminated from a couple
companies
and the people pointed out I don't I'll
say in my opinion because I want to be
careful on the legal issue
following The Exodus from patreon all of
a sudden these rival companies started
losing their access to online financial
services and it was very it was very
obvious what was going on
I think it is it is great that a rival
service emerges like locals but my my
belief is that if we are to succeed in
terms of Freedom Liberty into the future
we must Empower individuals to have
access to this to this technology at
their own fingertips immediately my
response was I'm going to start a
non-profit that creates a decentralized
open source patreon that anyone can have
for free to install on their own server
or server where they pay for it so
instead of going to someone else instead
of giving away a percentage of their
income and being behold into someone
else's political whims they can say it's
my server I upload I press enter on the
software instantly networked with all of
the other sites that use this have their
own privately controlled uh subscription
service and give money percentages to no
one it was a non-profit solution where I
said I don't want to make money off the
fact that people are being oppressed by
Massive manipulative monopolies and I
think that's terrific and and what Dave
rubin's solution was is and it's also
equally valid was I'm going to create a
service to to offer up to people a safer
position with their subscription
platform and for this I will get a
premium
what the reason I disagree with that and
don't like it is that Dave Rubin then
has the ability to sell those promises
to someone else off of the names he's
collected and he has Rumble I also think
is fantastic and we use Rumble fans but
what happens in 10 20 years has this
actually solved the problem no so what
it says to me is that we had this great
crisis moment and instead of solving the
problem individuals of Merit said we
will just recreate the same problem and
profit off of it that's fine because I
believe in free market all the stuff but
I actually think the solution to this
will be to create a Perpetual open
source community-based free networking
software to give to everybody I agree
that that is the solution but I'm also
saying that if there is a problem and
there's something that mitigates the
worst aspects of the problem that is
clearly a concrete agreement yeah
completely agree yeah I'm actually all
about people creating proprietary Tech
and selling it but the reason I went
after Dave so hard is because he's very
vocal about big Tech and the problems
and kind of beating big Tech and what he
did whether he realized they're not as
he built Big Tech he built proprietary
social networking and sold it to another
proprietary social network which can now
sell to Microsoft for six billion and oh
no I did not know that okay so so look
look I think that we need competition I
think that silicon Valley's Monopoly is
horrifying sure I think that Rumble
buying locals is massively beneficial
towards Freedom Liberty because it
creates competition and then puts these
other companies on notice Rivals are
emerging they're powerful and they're
taking away large portions of your
market share it's really really good
the end result I believe however is you
know I know the guys at Rumble and how
long will it be until an investor
because there are very big investors
involved in this who say what's my exit
and they say uh well I mean look Google
alphabet's really excited about what
we're doing and they want to buy up
competition so they're offering us half
a billion boom and then what happens
through you know a year or two later
they roll out new updates they roll out
so it's it's like it's like a stop Gap I
think it's still a net positive across
the board but it's just for me my
personal world view is we sh we should
be working towards decentralized
solutions that being said it's a net
positive what locals is doing what
Rumble is doing and I think Nothing is
Stopping Us from doing what we're doing
so in the end everyone's just doing well
and I'm just going to say one more thing
you know you said he sold me out he's
that site's giving me peace of mind
because people contribute five bucks a
month and I don't have to worry about
being homeless and I have to worry about
being canceled because if my Twitter
goes away if my YouTube goes away I know
I can make rent and that is really a big
deal for someone who's unemployable and
doesn't have a job that I can sleep at
night not worried about am I going to
wake up tomorrow is my life going to be
right so why my question for you is why
didn't you just spend the three hours to
install WordPress with the free
membership plugin what I don't even know
what you're talking about that's that's
the issue I take here you could have in
a matter of hours you can join my locals
for free
you just have to pay money to post
that's it it's free pay money to post
yes
like what do you mean it's
mouse.locals.com but my point is anyone
can join the community for free you do
not have to pay to join if you want to
be a supporter I have some hidden posts
and if you want to comment but that's it
but it's free right right so what I'm
saying is you have free content and then
member content right so for seventy
dollars you can buy a WordPress
it's a pre-made WordPress site like a
template okay and then I how much does
the that you can get like a membership
plug-in for a couple hundred bucks and
then the website is basically done and
people can do the exact same thing and
you never pay a cent of percentage to
anyone else ever again because this is
the first I'm hearing of this because
I'm a [ __ ] Boomer and this is my this
is my issue sorry my issue is I feel
like people got worried they were going
to have their lives destroyed by patreon
and Along Comes the person saying give
me 10 of all of your money and I'll make
it all go away when he could have said
Michael yelling because I I I am I am
I'm not not I'm not yelling I know
you're not yelling at me but yeah
because I tell people this all the time
you give me one day and I will give you
your own subscribe your own patreon your
own subscription platform and you will
never have to give away your Revenue to
anyone else but they go around and
collect those who are scared they say I
see a crisis people are scared their
livelihoods will be destroyed Lauren
Southern Carl Benjamin it is time for me
to go to them and assuage their fears by
telling them if you give me 10 of all
the revenue you make in perpetuity and
it is in perpetuity then I will make
that go away and when they called me and
asked me that I said I've run tech
companies before I've built apps before
in one hour I can make my own site and
they said no you don't understand how
hard it is Tim you're wrong you're wrong
about this trust me and give me 10 of
all your revenue and so I got a Dev
through Luke a good friend and for a
couple Grand we built our initial site
and we pay no one anything and the the
amount of growth we've had 10 percent
would be would be ripping money from our
pockets by exploding our fear years and
ignorance yeah I I look I'm Lefty on
these issues I am not the kind of person
who says buy or beware caveat mtor I
don't believe in that I believe that
that convincing someone to hand over a
portion 10 of their business and it only
cost me a couple hundred bucks to
operate their infrastructure is wrong
but you know what it is free enterprise
and I can respect entrepreneurial
behavior and if people make those
choices it is individual choice I feel
like I am actively combating things like
that trying to convince the good people
like Michael malice we can make you
powerful and we can make sure that money
stays in your pocket because I don't
want your money I don't want to be in
charge of you I don't want control over
your Revenue I want to help you on you
to be bigger and I want you to have all
the money in the world that you earn
yeah and then I watch these people come
up and say are you scared they're going
to ban you if you give me a cut of your
your money don't worry we won't and yet
still locals then sells to rumble and
Rumble could sell Now Dave Rubin made
you those promises but he doesn't have
control over whether whether or not you
get banned and I assure you locals will
ban certain people who sign up and we
all know it so what effectively happens
is you have built up your subscriber
base on someone else's platform once
again just like patreon and if you leave
it will be very difficult for you to
inform all of those fans where to go
they're getting a cut of your money and
it is it is a massive amount I I know
that I know the costs I know the
expenses we host members only content
and it is expensive because we have a
lot of members but if you were to host
everything you were doing on your own
website with your own couple hundred
bucks members plugin you would be paying
99 less than you would be paying now and
guess what they knew it when they sold
you it now that's that's free market and
if you're on the right and you're a
Libertarian and cap type you probably
are fine with it this is where I differ
and I believe I would rather
decentralize and give away the tech and
the power for free well the tech has
been out there for over 10 years so I
had my own website I called it a members
Lounge subscribers Lounge I call it Luke
uncensored.com right now it's been
around for a very long time and instead
of giving 10 instead of giving your
audience because also people who follow
you are going to go on that website and
they're gonna stay and they're going to
sign up to other people's uh you know
different kind of locals and groups you
could keep your own in-house group
directly to you because and there's an
email list yeah everything you have a
larger portion of your audience and what
you pay for is payment processing and
hosting which if you do it intelligently
is one to two percent compared to ten
percent and and real quick
Odyssey has
um oh I gotta link my stuff to there but
I believe they have because yeah because
look there's video there's video hosting
services that are decentralized torrent
based and the costs for them are
minuscule and you can get a membership
uh uh you can get member locked videos
on some of these platforms I'm not sure
if Odyssey does it open to the public
but I believe it's a business thing they
they do and it's we'll call it
effectively free yeah so I'll just put
it this way
when Pate when when Carl Benjamin is a
good friend of mine he helped when I
when I was starting my YouTube he said
Tim will you do a video for my channel
you know talking about something and
this was a huge opportunity for me he
had hundreds of thousand subscribers I
had none and then I broke 100k with his
support because there were people who
saw my work and believed in me and when
I saw him get banned from patreon over
BS issues I was personally offended they
lied they cheated and I spoke with the
CEO of patreon and he assured me all of
the exact same things that Dave Rubin
said as well I it was to the T I'm on
the phone with this guy in Vegas and
he's like listen listen man
I don't want to ban anybody we're here
to support Free Speech but here's the
issue when the processors come to us and
say you ban one person or you ban them
all we didn't do this we didn't trust us
we're here to protect you guys we
respect the creators and we assure you
we're gonna let you go and then I think
it was Lauren Southern first I think it
was after Lauren Southern had this
conversation and then it was caught he
said we'll never do this again without
giving notice I can't remember which one
was first but then Carl Benjamin got bad
I think he was second there was a mass
Exodus and then I'm like P like some of
these people are my friends whose lives
are being destroyed and this guy lied to
my face yeah he walked him up to my ear
yeah
and then Dave Rubin starts a business
and with all the good intentions again I
think it's a net positive and it's the
same narrative and now he's got you your
members are locked on his platform and
he sold it the promises he made to you
no longer matter because you don't know
who's in control of the investments into
Rumble which means tomorrow night you
could be banned and you could lose
everything more importantly 10 of your
revenue or whatever percentage they take
is substantially higher than if you just
took a day to do it yourself and that's
what Ian and I are dead set on Ian's
been running the on Foundation stuff
much more than I have but there's a team
of people doing this for free people who
used to work for big software
development firms who are excited to
produce a decentralized networked
software so when you install this on
your server all of a sudden you're
connected to all of the websites like a
big social media platform no one can
access your data because it's on your
server no one can ban you because it's
your server no one can take a cut of
your Revenue because it's going to your
financial accounts that's what we're
working towards yeah that's the awesome
Foundation it's a 501c3 charity after
January 1st you're going to be able to
donate tax deductible it's going to be
legit that we're going to be able to
start paying developers and kick this
into overdrive and make a metaverse that
is free software so that you can watch
the algorithms and see what they're
doing and and it's not going to be
spying on you the technology and it's
going to be awesome all the people who
sign up for this I don't want one red
Cent from any of you I want people to
have the right to free speech to be safe
in their careers and things they build
and after you build up your site and
through your hard work and dedication
and Merit you end up with a hundred
thousand paying members zero will ever
go to any of us who built it it will all
be yours now if you're an end cap you're
a capitalist you're you know whoever and
you believe that if you create it you
deserve a cut I do not disagree with you
we can both coexist no one's stopping me
from doing what I'm doing but I tell you
this my goal is to put all of those
companies out of business patreon
subscribe star and locals I hope that
our software ends them yeah and it was
Lauren I got hit first and I guess what
we're trying to say here in the short
concise way is decentralize and build
your infrastructure that's it yeah you
need the code to be free that's the
problem with rumble's private code
because it can spy on you and like sell
your data and and but you don't know
because you can't see that the code is
instructed to do it it's not just I'll
put it simply if you trust Dave you
could call him on the phone you're in
good position that's great
but Dave's not your guy anymore he sold
the company so I don't know who you call
now I like I like I'm sure it still
would be Dave I'm sure he's he's
involved yeah completely gone but but
selling the company
so who's on the board who's on the board
what happens when MasterCard calls up uh
Rumble and says look we got this guy
who's made some very offensive that's
what happened that's what happened with
patreon is with a swift payment system
came in and they were like we're gonna
shut it all down if you don't get rid of
personnel yeah yeah that's right that's
right no and so what happens then when a
financial service goes to a subscription
service and says if you don't ban this
one person we will shut down your
network they go oh no oh heavens what do
we do we have no choice what happens
when it's decentralized they go to the
one person they don't like and they
suspend his service and he opens a new
account with it with a merchant account
from another bank and it's and it's and
it's whack-a-mole but they can't ban
anyone else and they can't put the
network at harm because it's
decentralized so
with respect locals fantastic that's
awesome better than Dave Rubin better
than patreon you know patreon is bad for
a lot of reasons they're they're in the
Silicon Valley VC system
Rumble I believe is uh as well as in
Peter Thiel an investor in Rumble yes
yeah isn't he an investor in Facebook as
well I'm not sure no I'm not saying I
got beef with Peter Thiel he's actually
done some things I agree with but that
being said it's the same people who are
owning the same projects and who have
the same control and now that controls a
bit of relinquished back to Silicon
Valley so all it's done is tricked you
in my opinion into staying within their
ecosystem but giving you a false sense
of security now that the rights have
been transferred over
they've you know you build your platform
up on YouTube they could banish at any
moment on all those years of hard work
has been just annihilated so we're very
that that's why I'm like we got to do
our own timcast.com become a member
because that's where we persist in the
event they try to shut us down when we
start demoing I'll I'll try we could try
it out and it works all right it exists
it exists already right like the guys
had working versions of it no I wouldn't
call it working but it's like the
pre-alpha but the structure is there
like you can tell it's a building being
built the scaffolding is in place and it
is cool like you can like be in like a
3D realm I mean there's a lot of cool
stuff that that are that's being then
you can like paste uh up a website on a
wall in the 3D realm like we're really
kind of taking this all away I'm very
passionate about uh uh empowering other
people to be independent and all that
stuff it's like a driving force for me
but we went long we should go to super
chats okay smash that like button
subscribe to the channel I love my
locals it makes me feel happy that
there's a community of people who like
are friends with each other now
locals.malist.com
best case scenario of what exists that's
why we got to build something but I look
at it like with the patreon thing the
local situation is a plus one and the on
Foundation is a plus one thousand like
once once we get this Tech up and
running no one will be censored I mean
people will try and ban your bank
accounts they'll try and shut down your
servers they'll go for your hosts but
this is
imagine if your account on locals was on
your website no one could ban it that's
just the easiest way to put it or like
on a Raspberry Pi in your house that's
also mirrored on other people's
raspberry pies in their houses the
little tiny computers you put whatever
you want and then there's no one person
who can ban the network let's read super
chats because we because we went long
all right let's see riona and taka says
prosecutors knew who jump kickman was
and hit it yeah I saw that there was a
report there uh that they they believe
they know who the guy is who kicked Kyle
Rittenhouse while he was on the ground
and he fired at him but we'll see man
because the judge doesn't seem ready to
take action when the verdict comes in
the judge might say we're not doing this
that'll be interesting
all right let's see we didn't talk about
this maybe we'll talk about this in the
member segment OSHA has suspended the
vaccine yeah yeah yeah this is because
the fifth Circuit Court of Appeal I
believe Circuit Court of Appeals the pal
Court said unconstitutional for now
we're putting a stay but they say they
will move forward with it as soon as the
litigation passes through and they said
they think they'll win so the battle has
just begun
all right let's see hey Abbott says Hey
guys loving the timcast bonus content by
the way have you heard sad little man by
five times August it's a song he wrote
about fauci and today it number one in
the Apple singer songwriter tracks
have you guys heard of uh five times
August negative no but I thought that
song was about me oh uh uh five times
August there's like a bunch of like
political I think it's like acoustic
folk stuff I've seen a lot of it yeah
yeah yeah sounds sounds pretty good five
Leos I'm guessing five Leos I don't know
August
all right let's see um Gerald Armstrong
says Michael was also on Cash Cab that's
true I saw that I didn't know it was so
good it was really it's on YouTube
you're one of my Finest Hours you scored
and I I messed with Ben Bailey the
driver as much as I could because I knew
they were going to edit it out and at
the end he yelled at me and as soon as I
got out that cash cab they give you fake
money they mail you a check later I
looked at the camera and said this is
all going up my nose
they edited that out though right of
course but I'm like let me see what I
can say because let them sweat did you
just get into a random cab and it turned
out if you look up uh Thought Catalog
Michael Mouse Cash Cab there's an
article I broke it all down they
interview you pretending to be at
another show and they say they're going
to meet the producers at this place no
and if you watch my episode I point to
my hand because I'd written on it Cash
Cab wow like when I walk into the cab
yeah really yes wow and it's not just
the hat rack it's in the episode it's in
the episode yeah it says Cash Cab on
your hand you point to it I point to my
friend and I say cash everything's fake
on television everything so funny that
was brilliant gotta check that out
there's a very important Super Chat from
a member
Brony Ninja
you laugh but let's get serious
yes sir late Tuesday night I had to bury
one of my dogs oh listening to your
podcast this morning at work with uh
with only three hours of sleep kept me
from falling apart oh that's really
great I got a I'm a dog a bite victim so
oh yeah I'm a Survivor how's recovery I
wanna it's been traumatic I want to let
all of you guys know an important lesson
um it was several years ago that we had
to put down my dog that we had since I
was like 14. he was a Wheaten Terrier
Poodle mix named barley and uh I'm
already giving away too much information
and he was a very very very intelligent
dog and he got old
and he passed away we had to bring him
to the vet because he couldn't stand
anymore he couldn't go to the bathroom
and these things happen but I will tell
you this
when we were there it was one of the
most horrifying experiences I've had
sitting there seeing you know one of my
best friends and we have to watch the
vet yeah of course take his last moments
it was extremely painful to watch
because he didn't want to die my dog but
but he was he was already there at the
door
but I will tell you this in the
following days I would sporadically Cry
of course yeah I cried all night
for the next several weeks and months I
would randomly just start crying but I
will tell you I am happy the feeling of
sadness and depression and anger was one
of the greatest feelings I ever had
because that was all of the happiness
and joy that my dog had brought to me
just bursting from me at that one moment
randomly and I was crying because I was
remembering the love and the happiness I
was crying because it was gone but it
was a memory of the good and all of
those great things and I would never
give up any of it so in those moments
when I would cry remembering that my dog
had passed I would I would know I would
know as I'm crying that it was actually
tears of happiness for what I heard the
yes I had given the gift had been given
we all hung out on Saturday and I told
you on Sunday when the Great honors of
my life I went out with my friend Matt
to different kennels to help him pick
out a dog and we picked out a beautiful
girl and she's very smart she figured
out how to open the garbage she figured
out twice how to get out of the kennel
and she just goes into her crate by
herself she's a just an adorable Beauty
I have her picture on my Instagram I
always had dogs my entire life and my
family always had dogs their entire life
and there's incredible stories of dogs
protecting them there's dogs that saved
my grandmother's life and I wouldn't be
here if it wasn't for the relationship
that my family and my lineage had with
dogs so there's I have crazy insane
stories with with just um yeah there's
something else to them shout out to Lily
the cutest Frenchie on Earth who's that
it's she's in L.A all right what's up
all right let's get back to the
silliness Joe the op says is the
underwear model a new intern Tim
uh we have an underwear model on the
show yeah
it works for oh man you know what we
should talk about in the member segment
that tweet I had that triggered the left
oh my god with the sex works yeah yeah
aren't I smart Michael
sure
here I am on your show
all right so for those I I'm not going
to say the Tweet because YouTube would
get mad at me but I had a question about
oh my God yeah let's discuss this in
this I think it's a really I think it's
a I was a legitimate question I wasn't
PL I wasn't being silly you're like kind
of silly because the way I craft right
exactly yeah but it was a basically
question about the sex positive feminist
view of sex work and there's a really
really good question that I I thought
needed to be I I was it was a shower
thought I was just like you know not a
literal shower thought but I was just
like they said you know sex work is work
and I went is it then can an employer
make requirements we'll talk about that
in the member segment let's read some
more Super chats
all right John R says once an alcoholic
always an alcoholic same with
cannibalism that we talked about that uh
some of the people at Cass Castle I I
don't know about that because a lot of
AAA is like you all every day you wake
up and you tell yourself I'm an
alcoholic like how does that help you
kick it works confrontation facing your
problems not the only method but also
the reason AA says is it's not the
Caboose that kills you it's the first
car so by thinking of yourself as an
alcoholic you know you're not in a
position to say well I could just have
one drink now exactly because you know
your pattern is to get blackout drunk
but what's the difference if it says
getting up every morning feeling like I
am a danger to society like if you tell
yourself that aren't you just going to
become more of a danger to society I
tell myself that before I hit the gym
into the mirror yeah I am a danger
someday I'll have a reflection I think
that it's more about them more about the
community of aam that's a big part of it
yeah then then telling yourself what and
apparently LSD if you read Bill W uh I
think Bill W's the guy that founded a
okay he credits a lot of his kicking
alcohol to LSD but they removed it from
the literature oh wow all right Captain
says Adam Baldwin is the best Baldwin
how dare you so how dare you stop there
Adam I should be in school it's the
other side of the ocean Adam Baldwin is
an actor who's not part of the Baldwin
family who's actually like based I
assumed he was Alex brother no no that's
good to know okay is it the guy from
Backdraft is that Adam Baldwin he's the
guy from uh full metal jackets
Kaiser go to high school one of the
Baldwins Adam Baldwin's also in the
Patriot with Mel Gibson oh I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure right I think
you're right oh I love that yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure that's true he
plays he plays the traitor oh I'm pretty
sure he plays the trade yeah a turn coat
all right let's see but I love that
movie so much man
Enigma says question isn't calling Reza
Aslam accountable forever the same
argument the left makes about the
founders in slavery doesn't that
Viewpoint completely validate them when
they say they are nothing but evil no
the founding fathers many of them were
slave owners that will always be true
that doesn't mean we throw away all of
the good things they fought for it means
we we denounce the evils of slavery and
we we criticize to a extreme degree the
horrors that were perpetrated
by founding the founding fathers who
were slave owners which is almost all of
them and then we point out the ideals
that they put forth the seed they
planted helped end slavery and it led to
brilliant people Frederick Douglass and
so we championed the good while
condemning the bad and we remember both
so we know what not to repeat and what
to expand upon and I don't think I would
feel comfortable calling him a cannibal
I think cannibalism involves murder and
involves human flesh as opposed to like
if you're or like extreme situations
also this is kind of like what is being
gay he's cannibalized is being gay but
he's not a cannon is being gay wanting
to have sex for someone of the same sex
or actually blessings
can I say one sentence though when I was
doing just like with with Cash Cab I'm
like let me throw out all the jokes and
let them worry about adding later when I
was doing my book on the new right I
asked that very question and it was a
mainstream publisher and I had the line
are you gay if you're on your knees but
your heart isn't in it because I know I
knew my editor would cut it out and he
left it in and I'm like okay so it's in
the book same with cannibalism you know
if you don't want to do it but you do it
or if you want to do it and you don't do
it like Ryan long
has it has a man in the street bit where
he asks this question we'll talk about
this actually this is really good in the
member segment because it's all not
family friendly but the Ryan long
segment uh comedian you guys probably
know him was hilarious the way he talks
to people on the street and asks them
the same question is just well let's
read some more let's read some more we
got BlackRock beaconess as the
theological term for willfully
benefiting from The Acts of evil is
appropriation of evil allowing evil to
take place without resistance is
complicity with evil specifically
mediate immediate material cooperation
banality of evil only implies that it is
commonplace wow that's really great
really great Super Chat thanks BlackRock
because that's very insightful
David Strasser says certavich rocks Tim
uh give out our small business grossed
vodcast on YouTube shark bite Biz Gwar
is airing Monday morning right on
let's see Balian says if Gage did all
these horrible things to kids how is he
able to possess a gun no no it was
Rosenbaum who did the horrible things
Gage grosskreutz just like smacked his
grandma I think something like that and
he was he really likes Prodigy
that's what their songs
[Laughter]
not Grandma I now remember the song I
wasn't I wasn't big into uh what band
was it again Prodigy The Prodigy I think
there the project no that's is it done
maybe it is
Ivan Chavez says I feel that evil is
much like cold and dark it's the absence
of cold is the absence of heat dark is
the absence of light and evil is the
absence of good no no a lot of evil is
so intentional it's not just passive
it's predatory and intense yes yeah
that's the intensity because like it's
like electricity a little bit is good it
makes your heart beat but a lot of it
can kill you uh it could be considered
good is the visible light spectrum which
warms our skin and we enjoy and evil is
the ionizing radiation which destroys
our DNA and kills us yes cancer there
you go so the intensity of good is evil
hugging someone to death what give me
that the intensity of good is evil you
can be so overwhelmingly good that you
are committing horrible acts I think
well C.S Lewis has that quote but he'd
rather be under the thumb of someone
who's corrupt than someone who's a
do-gooder exactly because a do-gooder
will never let you sleep yep because
he's doing it with the with the benefit
is unconsciousness it's yin yang right
I'm not saying it right well you're like
Asian I don't know I know so um you know
yin yang you have the white and the
black yeah the Dow but within the white
there is within the light there is dark
within the dark there is light so they
say that there is good and there is evil
but within good there is Evil Within
evil there is good
so that's it's it's like a symbol of the
balance Redemption but I I think about
can you do good to the point where it's
evil definitely utilitarianism
Thanos and and like I'm gonna kill half
the you know you know universe's
population to save the other half he
wants to save quadrillion like here's an
either easier example when you are not
allowing someone to make their own
mistakes and you're like saying I'm
gonna make the choices for you and those
choices are genuinely good you are
committing some Act of evil because this
person is not having a sense of self
helicopter feel good
lawful good they tend to be can become
insane people that are lawful good can
be completely insane because they'll
zealously attack evil at every
possibility
that's the thing ignorance can lead good
people into dangerous yes evil territory
true neutral is the only way it's one
way
laughs
all right what do we got we need some
super jets here
okay
Boop
nerdiest Maximus says how can Kyle be
tried as an adult on murder when the
foundation of the state's case was no
self-defense because he illegally had
the gun as a minor that wasn't the
premise of their case the state wasn't
arguing that it wasn't self-defense
because of the gun they didn't argue
that they just argued he was too young
to have a gun that's it
yeah I think it was a mistake a lot of
people made when they were like the left
was saying it and I said it early on
tune was corrected that he's in the
commission of uh he's in the he's in the
uh act he's in the act of committing a
crime therefore he can't be in
self-defense because he's committing a
crime and people were quickly like no no
no no no no no no that's not true that's
not true so it turns out anyway the gun
charge was dismissed he was legally
allowed to possess it so it's moved
anyway if there's a mistrial now with or
without prejudice can they reintroduce
the gun charge or is that completely
unadmissible Evermore you guys know I
don't know that'd be a question for
cerno yeah
Josh a says Rogan's meme about Alex is
outdated human monkey Chimera are
already a thing 2021 415 NPR human
monkey embryos kind of his point was
like they were just checking him off
today the humansi legend has it was made
in the 1900s you know the story about
the humanzi well this is being Stalin is
he the one who did it well Stalin was
trying to make a like a super race of
like breeding humans and apes wow yeah
is that for real double check it Lydia
please
was Adam Baldwin maybe my source was in
it it was Adam Baldwin it was Captain
Wilkins I think yeah
[Music]
let me look that up
I just stolen
Kyle uh Petty says please ask the lawyer
about the prosecutor advising the
investigator to use Marcy's law as an
excuse to not fulfill the warrant to
obtain bicep Man's phone uh well Mike
had to go uh certificate had to leave he
was our lawyer but uh I don't know if we
have any analysis on that I don't know
if you're I don't know Marcy's law was
where it was like we can't subject to
the victims to you know police force in
this Direct in this way so but I think
it's an excuse I think they were alike
we want you to testify he was like no I
plead the fifth and they were like what
if we give you immunity we can't say we
give you immunity because that'll hurt
the case but what if we you know come on
you know what's really crazy in the in
the closing arguments the state said
that the zaminski's have a Fifth
Amendment right to to plead so a Fifth
Amendment right to remain silent
and the defense objected
the defense was correct
this the judge would not uh sustain this
and it was wrong what they said was the
defense cannot call the zaminski's the
guy who fired the gun in the air because
he has a right to remain silent and
doesn't want to implicate himself but
the state controls whether you have a
Fifth Amendment right or not because
they can offer immunity which means the
state could have called the zaminski's
given him immunity and then gotten
evidence against Rittenhouse but they
didn't likely because their narrative
was not true the judge should have said
you can't claim they have a Fifth
Amendment right because you can take it
away with immunity by force
if the state comes to you and says
you're testifying you say I plead the
fifth they say you've been subpoenaed
and you have immunity you have no choice
they can take it away but if they don't
give you immunity then you do have the
fifth yes okay but that means they
control whether or not you testify in
the defense has no ability to do that
the defense can't give you immunity so
you played the fifth
all right
garhead says Michael could you please
reach out to Mike Rowe and have you
travel America doing Blue Collar jobs
with Mike it would be awesome Odd Couple
watching a New Yorker hoeing corn or
doing a roof first of all I'm gonna text
in and not even a gunpoint
[Laughter]
I don't know Mike I interviewed him
before
um and he's a very very uh interesting
blue-collar guy and he's making a lot of
very good points throughout all of this
madness that I think is definitely worth
paying attention we are we are some
point yep wait I love that guy yeah we
are he's already in the works okay
perfect yeah I'm a big fan yeah yeah
he's he's such a good dude where he's
like you know work hard and do your
thing and I'm like yes he's a realist I
I had a lot of fun interviewing him he's
he's great super cool guy yeah
okay let's try and find something good
we got uh we got a big one here
Theodore uh Abate Abbott says Washington
was Zero for four before he crossed the
Delaware he wasn't a born military
General he figured it out because that
was what was required he was only
promoted in the French and Indian War
because his CEO fell off his horse and
died the founding fathers were all just
humans Who Rose to the occasion I
watched this crazy documentary about the
Congress and and building up to the war
and everything and Washington would go
in every day to Congress every day he
went in in his military uniform blue
before War had ever been discussed just
letting everyone know without saying the
word I'm ready and he never spoke he
barely ever spoke he just sat and
listened and they also thought he was
sterile by the way oh interesting he
never had any kids Martha who had kids a
while and then the Congress voted they
were like we got to pick somebody to
lead this thing and they picked him and
because he was a Statesman he didn't
become a Napoleon I think a big part of
this because he understood law and maybe
because he was friends with the other
fathers but I think it's more that he
just understood judiciousness and law
like the point it was just a military
and he also want to very clearly have
the president the president is very
different from a king because they
didn't know what to call him his
Excellency you're mad he goes no no Mr
President is what they settled on
all right Matthew fumi says actually the
Pennsylvania Senator spent near eight
thousand dollars on his campaign the 153
dollars was what was spent during his
primary which he ran unopposed he was on
crowder today and talked about this uh
the guy we're talking about is in New
Jersey yeah yeah
the New Jersey state senator ran against
a Democrat to keep the majority leader
you're right and beat him and the
Democrat refused to concede for a for a
little while and finally he did concede
he finally conceded yeah okay yep yep I
don't know what the Pennsylvania thing
is though not sure interesting still not
much money 8 000 bucks yeah yeah oh here
we go a lot of Adam Baldwin fans John
Curry says Adam Baldwin played Jane in
Serenity and Firefly yes that's right oh
very cool so excellent Firefly yes uh
Sarah Hart says Adam Baldwin is in
Patriot also Jane and Firefly very cool
all right let's see
what does that say
blue shirt tale says Tim you asked if
you can do so much good it becomes evil
Aristotle addressed this 2500 years ago
quote any virtue taken to excess becomes
a vice
I hate that it's a little simplistic
right yeah it's it's just semantics
right yeah it's just you know too much
too much love what equals minus one yeah
yeah
too much cheese equals farts
too much love like what would too much
of anything is bad obviously but by
definition you're saying too much right
yeah
I think if someone is kind 24 7 to the
day they die like genuinely kind that's
not a sin um reminds me of that South
Park episode where they meet the Mormon
family have you ever seen that in the
Mormon family is just really really good
people and they're just like they're
they're they believe you know this thing
that that the rest of South Park finds
weird but they're all just good people
and finally they're on the end they're
just like you guys are you guys are
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right one more one more
semper Ives says Tim Marine Corps
birthday was November 10th birth in a
bar called ton Tavern imagine getting so
drunk with the boys you create the
deadliest fighting force in the world
Captain Samuel Nicholas did that's great
that's great like one of uh dankula's
dudes a captain a captain in the
military started the Marines or I don't
know much about I don't know anything
about this story I've never heard of
this before all right everybody here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna have a
members segment coming up where we talk
about naughty things and it's going to
be really really funny so I hope you're
ready go to timcast.com become a member
it should be up around 11 or so you can
uh don't forget to subscribe to this
Channel smash the like button share the
URL of this video wherever you can
because that's how we fight the
censorship it really does help the show
and follow us at timcastiro basically
everywhere you can follow me personally
at timcast Michael you want to shout
anything out sure uh you can follow me
on Twitter at Michael malice I got
Robert Barnes discussing the
writtenhouse case on youtube.com Michael
milesofficial and of course
sheathunderwear.com promo code malice
look isn't that the anarchist audiobook
which Tim read a chapter of yes honor
the distribute distributor cleared it so
it's going to be percolating out to
wherever we get audiobooks over the next
coming weeks and that's awesome I know
I'll update on twitter.com I'll update
at malice.locals.com definitely there
you go
there's a lot of very interesting
comments about what people were wearing
today especially when we were talking
about the felony bit I'm going to save
it for the after show but my YouTube
channel is we are change I have a lot of
fun on there in yesterday's video You
Could See Me translating German and if
you're interested in that you'll go to
youtube.com forward slash we are change
I hope to see some of you guys there I
love you guys so much thank you so much
uh last night was one of the most
surreal greatest moments of my life
like unbalanced as well yeah I couldn't
sleep but I was like I was too hyped up
there's too much energy beautiful
reality thanks for coming Ian Crossland
see you later thank you guys for tuning
in again while we're touring Austin and
our super awesome little sketchy RV that
Joe Rogan was unsettled by we're having
a lot of fun down here thank you all for
continuing to tune in you guys may
follow me on Twitter at Sour Patch Kids
hey Linda honey listen yeah I know I
know you guys thank you all so much for
for subscribing and sharing we have 1.3
million views on yesterday's show it was
wild and insane to clarify it was it was
Alex Jones
Blair white Drew Hernandez Lydia
all right everybody go to timcast.com
you're not going to want to miss this
one it's going to be dirty and naughty
and we will see you all at timcast.com
bye guys